uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey you guys happy friday
yep it's open lines friday here we are i
know it's just like it's just like the
art bell show yeah they're starting to
pile in got about nine or ten of them
there was ten few minutes ago no one
slipped out
they'll be showing up though
just uh on open lines friday
you can uh bring up anything in the
comments section we can talk about it
if you have any questions about any of
the cases blah blah blah blah you're not
stupid you know what i'm talking about
well uh anything you want we will uh
talk about today
so i'm [ __ ] tired
uh yeah well you got more sleep than me
though i think right
yeah but i rode an hour and a half to
the va and an hour and a half back i
spent on [ __ ] all day was on a
[ __ ] motorcycle oh okay make it
sleepy because i woke up at like 4 00
a.m i couldn't go back to sleep for
whatever reason yeah like you do like i
do yeah i'm getting insomnia in my old
age
you know what i mean
i don't know
[Laughter]
you get sensitive
what are you talking about you get real
sensitive [ __ ] a cat will [ __ ] run
across you and you'll wake up or [ __ ]
if i say something in my sleep you go
what huh
like go back to sleep
well you're never tired
huh you don't ever really seem to be
tired
i'm tired all the time i'm just so used
to being tired that it doesn't register
as being tired just because i'm just
used to being tired all the time
but um
well no i wake up i woke up this morning
because i had because i had to pee
and sometimes like and then you know i
got back in bed and then i couldn't go
back to sleep okay sometimes it's too
hot in the room
sometimes
uh you know pookie jumps on my head it
doesn't bother me i mean she just wants
to
come in and
make biscuits on somebody
i guess she gets lonely in the middle of
the night and i can hear her munching on
her little treats over in the corner
but you know
i don't know what it is i don't know
what it is
but
i think i fell back to sleep for like
half an hour or something but not really
and then at like a little past seven i
just got up and got on my damn exercise
bike like i do
got dj maniac in there saying we don't
make it need to make a call and show he
can call him right now on facebook
messenger
do we know how to even use that
well i know how to use it but i don't
know
i don't know i don't know okay i don't
think it's gonna i don't know how it
would go through obs i don't know how to
do that yeah
so yeah we don't know what would happen
if you called bro
[Laughter]
yeah i don't really know should so
should i show um
bee's nest
scent
it was bee's nest right yeah he said
this i don't think he's on yeah there
should i wait until he's there before i
show because he because he was like well
you have to wait until yeah when he's
here we should
now send us something from mexico
yeah yeah i mean i put a picture of it
on instagram sort of i didn't like show
the whole thing but
we could show we could always show it
again yeah
so he sent me this
this classy [ __ ] yeah this is classy
as [ __ ]
it is
a shot glass with some with it with some
weed on the front or is that or maybe
that's uh maybe maybe an agave i think
it's agave plant because i just like
glanced at it quick and i was like it
looks like a pot leaf but i think it's
agave and then
on the top of it it's got a mexican dude
with his pants down [ __ ] nearly
falling into the glass when you take a
shot your nose goes in [ __ ] right
right into his tail he's got [ __ ]
balls and [ __ ] you show it to him
yeah it's pretty i'm not sure will the
youtube algorithm think this is like
nudity
because i'm not really sure if you can
tell what it is but it's just kind of
like usually show it to the camera um i
didn't want to get too close just in
case it thinks it's porn but um
yeah i like the way i like the way the
little corona bottle is kind of like
just stuck to his thigh sort of yeah for
whatever reason
yeah we've all been there well you know
not really but
i guess he's falling into the shot glass
i guess so but like i said he's the it's
i'm trying to i'm trying hard to imagine
a scenario where this might have
happened like this dude ended up in this
particular predicament i don't know but
i think that he's just there like i said
because then when you drink out of it
like your nose just goes right in his
ball sack yeah i guess so and you like
everyone will think it's funny so you
know what i mean
that's how that goes
oh my god all right
so yeah you've been gone most of the day
you went to the va
yeah
um
i haven't been anywhere except for the
liquor store i just been working yeah
but
tomorrow i'm gonna drive to ocala and
see my mom and my sister spend the night
there
no
like i don't know
we'll see she asked me if i wanted to
and i was kind of like well i'll see how
long because i don't really like to
drive back from there in the dark
because there's not like
just been a night cell phone
just spend a night i don't know i might
i mean they're never in town
that's true
yeah that's true and i think my sister
is gonna stay over because uh she's
gonna get there tomorrow and then she's
gonna drive back to atlanta on sunday so
she's just gonna stay uh at their house
overnight so i don't know so maybe i'll
stay as well i'll take stuff with me and
then i'll see how i feel yeah yeah
that's how you do it i mean it's nice
though because
uh the house we moved to is actually
closer
to my mom's house than our old one
not hugely i think it's like 20 miles
closer so i think it only takes an hour
to get there instead of like an hour and
40 minutes like it used to but
that's nice anyway but like i said it's
kind of out in the middle of nowhere
so i'm always kind of nervous
about
driving there at night because uh
there's not a lot of cell phone
reception
and it's kind of out in the middle of
the ocala national forest
so
you know you don't want to break down
and then like be the first act of a
horror movie
kind of situation it kind of seems like
you know what i'm saying so i don't know
we'll see how it goes trying to get this
vodka to wake me up
yeah you need to wake up wake up
yeah
looking back here at the set
yeah i need to get like some more tables
and shelves and [ __ ] like that
i need more things to put things on
you know what i'm saying
yeah because i feel like
my shelves are packed full of stuff and
i've still got a bunch of stuff that's
just kind of like sitting around on the
floor yeah but
i don't know i can't really afford it
right now
i kind of want to do what i wanted to do
i need some more frames for some of my
other [ __ ] too like to put up there but
i thought maybe some of those little
cube things that you mount on the wall
that you can either use like just to put
stuff on or use them for books or
whatever i don't know
yeah john smith says sounds like the
start of a horror movie yeah that's
exactly what it is
uh
topics for rando discussion
uh let's see doo doo doo
okay one of these is funny how to make a
woman want you even when you were mgtow
[Laughter]
yeah you should you should read the
[ __ ]
how to build a chorizo
okay
um how to make a woman want you when
you're big tap
the zen of justin's he-man doll oh yeah
[ __ ] i remember that [ __ ]
uh which serial killer had the most
interesting hobbies
hobbies related to the serial killing or
just hobbies in general yeah
it's funny he's talking about justice
chester's [ __ ] he-man though
maybe i mentioned that on another uh
show if he did i don't know he had all
kinds of [ __ ] he-man dolls
when we were kids
back in high school up in trenton
michigan
my best buddy [ __ ] steve
who was he was a trip himself man that
guy
but um he was a legend
and then uh his little brother was
justin
that [ __ ] justin tore the whole
[ __ ] house apart
after after his parents got divorced he
left he just left his his mom was just
left in this damn house in fact he
didn't even have any damn
doors on the cupboards [ __ ]
the whole house was ruined man and it
was just because of justin
he was wait he just ate everything he
just [ __ ] destroyed everything he was
like a human goat
he was just a super rambunctious
and
i guess because he was the baby of the
family he just got whatever he wanted
you know and he was the truth man
although he outgrew it evidently it
became normal
well i hope so you don't really want an
adult man like he's you know he comes
home if he has a wife or something like
that he's like you've eaten every single
stitch of furniture in this house
it's funny man i make fun of pookie all
the time because she chews on that table
and i'm just like pookie's eating all
the furniture in the house he carried
around this little doll of a mouse like
about something to do with chuck e
cheese
and he called it grandpa
i remember you telling me that i
remember you doing he talked he would
talk to it in grandpa's voice and talk
about that
[ __ ] me and steven would be like wow
that's some creepy [ __ ]
stephen [ __ ] whatever ask grandpa ask
your aunt party no no no no ask grandpa
just [ __ ] funny it was like something
out of a horror movie actually
you think about it you know like playing
the creep that creepy kid like the
creepy kid thing you know like out of
amnesville you know jody yeah yeah his
version of judy was
grandpa dwayne paul you scared jody
i [ __ ] remember all about that
and he had all these little [ __ ]
he-man things he was probably about i
don't know graham could probably
remember i have a hard time placing kids
his age
he maybe he was about seven six or seven
probably
at that time okay
he's [ __ ] rambunctious as [ __ ]
yeah my mom used to babysit a kid like
that
because she had um
she ran a daycare out of our house for a
while and we had
probably five or six kids i think
uh and one of them what was that kid's
name chad yeah man that kid was just
[ __ ]
you couldn't turn your back on him for a
second
yeah dude be like hanging off the
goddamn ceiling fans yeah if you like
you know and i i think actually at our
house he was like climbing all over
something and fell and broke his [ __ ]
collarbone yeah
so you know well
me and steve where i guess we were
probably at the time that i'm talking
about i think we were juniors
because i did my senior year back in
that back in brazil
we were juniors at this time
and [ __ ]
and and he was jealous of us you know i
mean he was constantly trying to be
better than us at something
justin all right
and and his whole [ __ ] thing was uh
nintendo he had the nintendo one yeah
the nes yeah
and he was winning zelda
all right he'd sit there and beat zelda
and he would [ __ ] with us about yeah you
didn't finish you didn't finish [ __ ]
zelda you know what i mean if i could
that's the only thing that i can do that
you guys can't do steve would start
[ __ ] lying okay we'd start lying and
i'd help him lie just no we finished it
no where did you finish it finish it
while you were asleep dude
oh no it could have been it couldn't
have been because you know he'd start
calculating his mind you know if there
was enough time for us to beat zelda
and he goes well what happened on
something wrong then he he'd name some
[ __ ] out and [ __ ] steve would spin a
[ __ ] perfect lie that was so
non-committal
that a seven-year-old could buy that
maybe you did say that
one of the things was was [ __ ] debit
did you beat goma
and [ __ ] dude we beat [ __ ] we'd be
goldman what color was goma you know
and this is it's just well it hasn't
there were two
there were two of them the one that we
thought was [ __ ] green and he was
like what
and he goes what was the color of the
other one and i have just by [ __ ]
pure chance said blue
that's what color coma was and he went
right down this [ __ ] rabbit hole he
thought that there was a boat we had him
believing
because we lied okay we know all about
the power of the lie
that there was a [ __ ] hidden
level to where you had to beat
goma again gomez normally blue it's a
big crab looking [ __ ] thing all right
normally it's blue he says no no no
later on we fought the green gum and we
had that [ __ ] going for [ __ ] two or
three months he's trying to figure out
how to get green goma this is before
before the internet
you know you couldn't look it up
they just started to come out with these
little magazines that would tell you
yeah like the books and magazines
yeah and
me and steve were such [ __ ] great
liars that we had him and finally man
years later
i was on pass
from the army and went up to go see
steve all right and he was
he was there in that house and i don't
yeah he was there no he wasn't there
[ __ ] justin was there steve wasn't
there at the time
in fact justin was probably about
16 or 17 at that time and he goes i know
you lied to me about green gomer he
remembered it after all that he
remembered it
and it was like
and he traumatized that foreign
i was like oh yeah
no
and he was like i'd do it
[Laughter]
i was trying to [ __ ] find that thing
i played that game four times trying to
find that
it's [ __ ] funny
like sucker yeah
yeah you're so mean he's about 16 at
that time
i just think it's funny that he
remembered that no he remembered
everything he remembered everything we
did too that's really funny yeah i mean
people got really really big deal
yeah well people got really really into
those video games man i i get that my
brother was like that too like he got
really really into all those nes games
uh and he would just
he would play him over and over and like
if he kept [ __ ] up he would just
start screaming and like [ __ ] beating
on the floor and like that he was like
losing his [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh my god
yes sandra says poor kid sandra's name
today is sandra worked as a spy with
marie curie
madame curious
[Laughter]
two completely different women uh but
yeah but it gave me pause for a second
i'm like wait was marie curious by like
i'm perfectly willing to
to uh you know put it forward that maybe
she was and
that's just not coming out i don't know
um
and greg asked have you ever considered
doing a show about evp did we do a show
about evps
we've done we've mentioned the
manchester i kind of feel like we maybe
did yeah i don't know
i thought we did a show about evps but i
can't i mean if if we did it was a long
time ago i mean we might do another one
at some point this is i remember when
justin got sent to survival boot camp
for juvenile delinquents in northern
michigan i didn't know that would happen
oh my goodness that must have been ahead
of time he made that bomb
and blamed it on me
oh see i i haven't heard this story oh
you know about that no i don't think he
told me that during that same time
that i told him about green goma i was
in from the army all right
i found steve later but he wasn't in
that house he was in another house i
just rode somewhere else where he was i
just stopped into his family house first
to try to find him
and he's like he's like hey tom hey tom
hey tom
if you were to take
a bunch of match heads and pull the
the flammable material off of match
heads
and put that inside of a glass bottle
and then pat and then put a fuse to it
wouldn't it blow up and i said yeah it
would blow up it'd blow up i said but
why would you do that why would you go
through all that trouble yeah oh you i
said all you got to do is go down the
damn sporting goods store and go get a
[ __ ]
uh pound of [ __ ] black powder he goes
they sell black powder because yeah the
sporting goods store why did you tell
him that
i think he could do it
so he goes down you know little did i
know
[Laughter]
he goes down the [ __ ] sporting goods
store and buys a [ __ ] pound of
[ __ ] black powder that's all your
fault tom
it's either black powder pyramid x
and um because you could get it from
muzzle loaders and a miner can have it
or at least they could back then
i probably still can
so some they sold it to him at the damn
[ __ ] sporting goods store
so he takes it home and [ __ ] pours it
into a coke bottle and packs it
halfway and this is what i heard and
then he [ __ ] puts the fuse in it all
right and then
packs it the rest of half the way and
puts it
on the [ __ ] ledge
outside his friend's window
and [ __ ] lights the fuse and it blows
the whole [ __ ] window frame out boom
i mean
yeah and [ __ ] later on i heard about
it when i was back in town
and his mom because why'd you teach him
how to build a bomb says what
you told him how to build a bomb said no
i didn't what are you talking about and
she explained and and she refreshed my
memories oh i didn't tell him to do that
i just said that why would you go
through all the trouble of [ __ ] using
match heads just when you just go down
there and go buy some black powder
because he did that he blew the whole
side of a wall out of somebody's house
and i was just like that dumbass
yeah well that must be why you guys said
the jewel
i would imagine yeah
yeah so i see him later and he goes he
goes he goes hey tom hey tom hey tom you
remember you told me about the bomb and
i said yeah you [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
you do
dude that worked and i said yeah and he
goes it went off man and i said yeah
yeah well yeah
but no man it went off big and i was
like well yeah
but i didn't know you were going to do
that but yeah that went big
i thought it was just like like a like a
little bit like a firecracker i was like
no
no a whole bottle full of yeah a whole
bottle a whole coke bottle full of
[ __ ] black powder would go off and
buy like a stick of dynamite yeah yeah
and then just
oh yeah i got a lot of trouble
i got a lot of trouble for that well you
shouldn't have done it rightfully so i
just thought i just thought it would go
off like a firecracker and i was like no
you didn't
yeah it went off just you didn't know
how big a bomb is maybe he was even
smart enough to have asked you that
whole question about the match heads
just hoping that he would get you to
actually tell him how to make a real
bomb
do you think he was waiting do you think
he was that smart yeah but his weight
would have worked
yeah but you know like you said it yeah
it would have worked it just would have
would have been really yeah i just said
why why would you go through all trouble
and [ __ ] doing that and you can just
go get yourself well yeah there are much
easier ways right i'm not gonna say what
they are but i'm just saying
you can do that i mean there's lots of
easier ways yeah it's like these people
[ __ ] say well you see
we can't really do anything we don't
have any guns in my country and i just
started [ __ ] laughing all right you
give me a tool room and a [ __ ]
and a [ __ ] store and a hardware store
and i will give you a submachine gun in
a few months
the hardest part is making the magazines
you know i can make all that
and another thing is what's even easier
is any what's called field field
improvised explosives and field
improvised munitions they're very easy
to make you said be very careful
you have to know exactly what you're
doing and i'm going to [ __ ] tell
anybody how to do it the the
information's out there
you must be able to measure weight and
temperature
very very accurately sometimes if the
temperature is wrong you blow up
you blow up okay because you have to
make this [ __ ]
but it's all made out of [ __ ]
pool chlorine and other things and
things and some other stuff and
things and stuff things and stuff and if
you can measure it accurately and you
know the temperature and you can heat
things and you can keep certain ice
chests cool with water and you know and
your thermometers are accurate you can
make military grade
plastique you know which is that's but
there's much much easier stuff that you
can do involving you know
and folk everybody knows that one
ammonium nitrate fertilizer and fuel oil
well yeah a lot of people use that
as long as you know how to cure it you
know the you know the re the ratio
goes off good goes off real good
and you just have to know what's good
for what and what what is a high
explosive and what is a low explosive
and what's the difference and
no hell no you can [ __ ] do anything
and then
people always discount things like
diesel fuel and gasoline
you know which is the heart of a
civilization
without that you don't have modern
civilization so every model
every modern civilization you can get
kerosene diesel fuel and [ __ ]
gasoline and
there's a huge amount of stored up
energy in that
you just have to know what you're doing
you have to be creative
in fact
one man with a bic lighter
did tens of millions of dollars of
damage in his lifetime he was just one
of them damn serial art arsonist and he
just had an eye
he could he just can just see things and
go if i set that on fire with my lighter
it will burn this whole block down and
he was doing stuff like that
see you guys everybody's good at
something yeah he was just very talented
very talented artist in one of the worst
ways possible yeah very talented
arsonist you know
and it was funny he's burning down
people burning down whole neighborhoods
just so he could beat off
yeah had a whole cut in his hand that's
just the only thing that i've ever been
good at had a whole cut in his pants he
put his hands in his pockets and sit
there and just watch the [ __ ] burn
yeah
yeah
that's pretty weird when you think about
it yeah
pretty weird but uh with a with a with a
big lighter
costing less than a dollar
so
there is no such thing as a world of
safety you will never be safe you live
in a dangerous world
with dangerous people who are evil
hairless monkeys
and some of them are [ __ ] have a
talent for just wreaking [ __ ] mayhem
and chaos
you'll never make it safe
the best thing to do is just everyone be
aware and everyone have the skills to
defend themselves and you have to have
an even
keel and even platform where everyone
can take care of themselves that's the
best way
just sure as hell law enforcement can't
do it
not really
and we got cops right here in the
they're a good force you got to have
them
but if everyone were to go buck [ __ ]
wild all at once that'd be the end of
the cops you don't even need everybody
just a certain percentage of them
if five percent of the population became
uncontrollable it would destabilize the
civilization it just takes time
it takes time and it takes intelligent
action it's been done many many many
times in history
danny roland goes faces just saw that
2020 film underwater starring kristen
stewart it was pretty good so it's like
an underwater version of alien just
saying interestingly i saw um
one of my favorite horror channels
possessed by horror and she was doing
like her top five horror movies on every
streaming platform and she had she also
recommended that one it was talking
about how she recommended it to
everybody because it's like way better
than you think that it would be
um
oscar perez why did tom find hereditary
boring it's a top three horror movie of
all time i agree like uh hereditary
easily easily my favorite horror movie
the last
10 or 20 years i just can't explain it
or just something about the pictures and
the way the movie's edited it's kind of
one of those ones that yeah you're
either gonna like love it or but all
horror movies are like that horror is
very subjective
um summer yeah which is weird because i
thought it would have been the opposite
but yeah you loved midsummer but like
you know they're very very different
movies even though it's the same
director
but that's what's cool about it is like
he just did completely different
different [ __ ]
but uh yeah i mean i love hereditary i
think it's awesome
um let's see
okay so i answer that question
uh we never did answer granthar's
question about uh how to make a woman
want you even when you're a mgtow
well if you're mgtow like why would you
even want that
no they're calling me a bad influence
[Laughter]
i'm trying to catch up with whatever
jeffy art says just logged on and heard
someone say beat off what
yeah talking about uh some arsonists
yeah who are just you know yeah [ __ ]
grandparents knew all about [ __ ]
steve's [ __ ] special room downstairs
well it wasn't just steve we me and
steve shared that [ __ ] room down
there steve had built this room down
there
and that's where uh
you could go down there and [ __ ]
smoke smoke a dude would [ __ ] chill
out and you could also we were also
bringing our girlfriends down there that
was our like our [ __ ]
that was our damn
our [ __ ] mini motel love motel
that place is badass and justin wasn't
allowed back in back in there but that
sucker [ __ ] busted the damn uh you
know this uh
the the [ __ ] what was the
the paneling that they used to have back
there like a fake wood paneling that we
had yeah he pried some of it away so he
could [ __ ] slip in he would slip in i
found that [ __ ] in there one time
trying to get back out
did you [ __ ]
yeah oh my god yeah i was [ __ ]
throwing things at him he's trying to
get out to do the [ __ ] crack in the
wall
oh my god yeah it was in the basement
that's like some crawl space yeah this
room is about to be about the size of
this room and it had like a closet in
the back and ain't no grandpa's new
about that one
that's really funny yeah we had couches
in there
man me and me and steve [ __ ] wore
that [ __ ] out man with [ __ ] uh with
the girls that we were wearing we were
[ __ ] dating the girls you were
wearing i wear i said the girls we were
dating are you are you skinning girls
and wearing theirs yeah
yeah are you doing some leather face
action down there that i don't know
about
there's some buffalo bills yeah mary
lynn do that room well
yeah
uh yeah danny rolling ghostface says
kids love to burn [ __ ] when they're
young yeah my brother did uh as well he
used to set every [ __ ] thing on fire
uh he grew out of it but you know yeah
um he set the backyard on fire one time
one fourth of july that was exciting uh
yeah grampher says when i was a cop we
used to look for someone whacking off in
the shadows as an abandoned home burned
that would be suspect number one yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god
uh john smith says one of the uk's were
serial killers uh worst killers was a
serial arsonist who called himself bruce
lee killed about 26 people
holy [ __ ] i don't think i ever heard
about that
sandra says they're working on a mad max
sequel
and a separate curiosity film well we
heard that a long time ago i don't know
if i don't know if there's any new
information yeah have they like made any
progress on that because i do kind of
feel like i mean i'm i'm there for it
when they make them because they had all
those bad ass cars that they put in
mothball for the next movies they have a
lot of ideas
and uh the director i can't remember his
name uh uh george miller yeah george
miller uh miller said that
he had several
uh students working underneath him that
could execute all kinds of [ __ ] mad
max movies once he's gone so he promised
that there would be more mad max he has
chosen once
that can can do man like you can do mad
max and you can
you can't do math yeah you can not you
though there are certain people doing
that kind of [ __ ] there's people who
understand you know
uh and evidently the ones that
the ones that he is kind of knighted to
to take his place had a lot to do with
fury road
so i think that's good i think it's a
good sign
yeah i mean
with i mean yeah [ __ ] man they needed to
do more of that
we had to go uh red a little bit but i
think it came back
yeah yeah uh yeah he was only convicted
of manslaughter so he was not high
profile his trial was also at the same
time as the yorkshire ripper oh okay so
he was overshadowed all right i'm gonna
have to look that up then yeah yorkshire
ripper was kind of like a big case i
read a bunch of books about that
uh yeah sandra says i think the furiosa
and the first uh mad maximum should be
released in 2023. this hope so so not
this coming year but the year after that
it's good
because miller's still around yeah he's
so lucky yeah he's still kicking i like
how he just [ __ ] came up out of
retirement [ __ ] just showed hollywood
how to make a [ __ ] movie
fury road i mean he kicked ass
like i said when i wrote about it when i
read about on my blog because like i
said we saw it in the theater like six
times yeah i was like yeah george miller
comes out of retirement and like this
movie drops and then he's just like
like walking away from the explosion in
slow motion yep putting sunglasses on
[Laughter]
movie was so awesome that a lot of
people thought that that that it wasn't
real that a lot of it was cg like oh
that guitar wasn't shooting fire out of
it and they didn't really do the [ __ ]
oh no that all that [ __ ] was real yes it
was it was all real watch all the behind
the scenes
they totally did all that guitar that
shoots fire
uh fire blowing out of stuff the [ __ ]
trucks blowing up even though even the
last crash where they had the [ __ ]
rock concert [ __ ] mobile is falling
apart and all the [ __ ] flying off of it
it does look fake but it isn't that's
it's just shot at a certain frame rate
makes it look kind of yeah the only
thing that cgi obviously is just that
wheel that's coming at the camera like
3d but other than that it was the whole
rack was yeah because we we have the
blu-ray and they and they have all that
[ __ ] on the um behind the scenes stuff
they use the only the cg was only used
to erase tire tracks and to r and to
erase safety harnesses yeah
which that's you know that's what that's
a great that's what you use cg for
yeah like i said i don't [ __ ] on cg just
because it's cg and it's like oh i don't
like new things it's just that
you know you can rely on it too much
just like anything else
and i like i said i'm really glad that
you know at least in the horror context
it does seem like people are heading
back toward
doing more practical effects because
those are always just gonna look better
when they're well executed and the war
the war rig worked
the blade on it and everything all that
[ __ ] that you saw the the war rig do it
did all that
it's amazing
they were in there building that [ __ ]
yeah like like i said you i mean just
the [ __ ] craftsmanship behind that
like in all the stunt performers and
everything like that i mean it's just an
incredible
it was just an incredible like piece of
art really yeah and then all the
decorations in the inside they were all
hand done the little skull faces it was
all
tapped in there and
you know they made special steering
wheels all decorated you know it was
cool real cool
saunders says man tom i can't believe
you had never seen fight club i didn't
see so much a tom film yeah no i totally
understand it one of the greatest films
of all times see i told you one of the
greatest films of all time like i said i
was very shocked that you had not seen
it but yeah
we put the review for that up earlier
that's why yeah earlier today
there's a lot of movies like i said i
just i kind of feel like
man talking about fight club made me
want to watch zodiac again for christ's
sake
zodiac is so good i watched excalibur
again
yeah we watched i didn't i i'd missed
like the first
well how long had you had it on it
seemed like i didn't know how much of it
okay yeah that is the first hour okay
that's a long ass movie i forgot two
hours long yeah
but that movie holds up
it sounds perfect yeah i mean that movie
it's it's very arthurian but then it's
like super weird it's strange because
watching i think we watched excalibur
and then later when i saw zardoz
um i didn't really associate the two
things like i knew it was the same
director but it didn't really seem
i don't know it didn't really seem the
same to me but now that we just watched
zardoz and then we watched excalibur
again i could see how kind of similar
they were
although obviously excalibur is a much
better film
but
i don't know
it it still has that like really weird
tone like zarda like zardoz had well
it's being told to you as as mythos yeah
as mythology
so
it has an unreal quality to it and it uh
real good costumes good acting
everybody's [ __ ] over the top
uh you know pissed off super hot hyper
macho
but you're dealing with barbarians
you know and you're dealing with
arthurian legends it you can't
you can't do you can't do realism really
the tone can't be realism or or the
whole thing's lost
it has to be fantasy
fantasy adventure like star wars that's
that's what it is anxious star wars
yeah because i mean the arthurian
legends
that aren't really a realistic
story it's all morality tales yeah
it has like a little bit of a fairy tale
kind of like vibe to it too well the old
ways are dying out in the new ways the
era of man and and and jesus are all
coming in
so
it shows you that
remember yeah because um
merlin is saying well you know our
time's gone and you know we're going
away so the old ways are going are
leaving and uh the new era is beginning
and
so
so they make sure to they kind of have
the movie has its foot in in both realms
of fantasy and religion
which that's what it is
yeah yeah
john smith says i loved fury road when i
saw it it was great world building
telling you enough about the immortal
joe cult with just small hints
honestly it's one of the best examples
of show don't tell that i have ever seen
in film ever yeah i said if i was
teaching a film class and was trying to
illustrate that principle that is the
movie i would show because so much stuff
is going on in there and there is so
very little dialogue
um but the world is so rich it doesn't
have to be
uh you know they don't have a lot of
exposition you just figure it out from
all these like context clues yeah which
i think is so great and like i wish more
movies would do that
there's a licensed um illustrated novel
to give you the backstory uh
of a morton joe and and uh
the guy who ran the bullet farm and the
people eater
tells you who they all were it tells you
who knucks was
how nux got in there how he got into the
damn
into the citadel
he got in as a child just holding on to
that damn ramp that you know those
platforms that moved up and down
and they were just betting on whether or
not he would fall but he never did fall
so they pulled him up and they said they
said you're a hard knucks to crack
that's what they said so his name was
nux he had nuts
hard nuts he had it hard enough to crack
these are man because he wouldn't give
up so that's how he got in there
but mor the immortan joe
morton was a um
he was a uh
i guess australian special forces guy
and so was the guy who ran the bullet
farm
and him in a small army of guys fought
their way into the citadel and took it
from some other dudes
and it was overwhelming odds and they
almost got killed and he ran ran across
a damn pipe to get there when he was
young and did all kinds of [ __ ]
so because he he had survived
overwhelming odds they thought that he
was impervious to death that he was
immortal so they just started calling
him the immortal the immortal and then
that it that evolved into the immortan
and then they divided the realm the
people eater was just some fat dude that
they found they were gonna kill him but
they realized that he was a mathematical
genius he could do all kinds of
mathematical
uh uh
computations in his head
and the they kept him around as kind of
like a human computer
and uh they made him like he ended up
getting real rich with them the people
eater
you remember the guy with the without
the nose the big fat guy yeah the one
with the gout what would the gal yeah
with the big hole swollen feet
he was just some uh dude they were gonna
kill
they were they just when they found him
they were just gonna kill him he was he
was begging for his life and they knew
who he was but they found out real quick
that he was a mathematical genius so
they kept him
and they wanted to see how that would be
kind of like uh good to have well he
could compute
what how many supplies you needed and
how far things were and could do it all
in his head and um
you know so it was like having your own
laptop so they needed him
yeah i could see that yeah
grantha's hammer says my dad took me to
excalibur and covered my eyes during the
scene where arthur was conceived by the
knight who wrote in on dragon's breath
that was pendragon uther pin dragon i
remember watching excalibur i think they
showed it to us in school like in 10th
grade when we were learning about the
arthurian legends like we were doing
like english lit or whatever
and uh
it's funny because the only thing i
remembered
from the movie
was
uh helen mirren and you know being cool
as [ __ ] in it and the dude playing
merlin being cooler [ __ ]
being cool as [ __ ] in it and also that
crow picking out that night's eye yeah
like the the tree with all the dead
knights hanging from it and then come in
and
i remember that yeah that was the scene
with mordred and the [ __ ] the tree
with all the dead nights in it
the guys that weren't any good
from his point from
his beliefs from his standpoint it's a
good movie i was thinking that while we
were watching it again last night i was
kind of like man that [ __ ] mordred uh
armor would make a kick-ass
cosplay wouldn't it
what has anybody done that i'm sure
somebody in the world has done it it's
just a gold armor with a damn
sun
face with the exposed jaw look good
yeah i had forgotten how cool that
looked yeah and it and it went like with
the whole like he even had a gold sword
right and there was like all the gold
like [ __ ] on his horse and everything
yeah he was impervious evidently
remember that they said nothing could
harm him when he had that on although
arthur yeah because it was like magic
armor yeah although arthur ran a damn
spear through him yeah but that was
excalibur was it no it was a spear
was it it was a spear it wasn't
excalibur
no see i thought yeah he won't put a
spirit through his head and then he used
that celebrity don't tell me that's
right i saw the same movie
i know that was the other way around
[Laughter]
yeah sondra also liked mid-summer much
better than hereditary so it does i mean
like i said i liked both movies uh both
of them are awesome
um
but i don't know like i loved mid-summer
but i really really liked hereditary
like i really long
i saw i saw um hereditary twice the
first time i fell asleep in the theater
second time we saw it was okay
um it was good it was just uh it just
wasn't really that satisfying for some
reason
you know
midsummer had more characters in there
more [ __ ] happened
um you had a little what's her name that
cute little
chick with the lollipop head her head
like a little lollipop florence beard of
course yeah
she was from i really liked her and
fighting with my family [ __ ] great
god that was such a good movie i feel
like more people should see that it's
just so so charming sadr if you haven't
seen fight with my family you gotta see
it it's a florida movie and it's got
that girl in it and it's based on a true
story based on a true story and they
show it a lot of stuff happens in it
right near where we used to live
we used to drop drive by at all times go
to the club
going up i-4 remember that yeah the uh
the where where they were training
during recruiting or in that damn
building yeah yeah yeah i mean it's
about um
wrestling but you don't have to give a
[ __ ] about wrestling like to enjoy the
movie a lot more than that yeah it's
just like a fun like character and it's
funny yeah real funny like you know and
her like all the her family dynamic is
hilarious right like i really like um
like her mom and dad and stuff it's like
trashy british council estate [ __ ] but
they're funny they're cool and then it
comes into like florida yeah and the
difference and and and how she's getting
along and she's kind of a gothy chick
and like she comes over and like to get
all these kind of hot you know
yeah models and dancers and stuff
they're all becoming wrestlers and she
doesn't respect them she's like oh you
guys aren't real wrestlers you're like
porn stars or something
because they all yeah they all look like
foreign
this is kind of the same scene yeah
um
john smith says one of my favorite sword
and sorcery movies when i was a kid was
dragon slayer i remember liking that
when i was a kid but i haven't seen it
in a really long time in a long time i
kind of feel like that might be one of
the ones that if i watch it now i'll
just be kind of like
i don't know maybe not maybe maybe it'll
hold up best sword and sorcery movie for
me is conan cohen and a barbarian the
first oh yeah everybody knows that and
then after under right right underneath
that would be excalibur
i don't remember dragon slayer that much
i remember seeing it was thinking it was
okay
i saw it on cable a lot i kind of feel
like
it wasn't one that i watched over and
over i kind of feel like maybe my
brother was more into it if i'm
remembering right i mean this is a long
time ago
um
and i don't remember if i like sat there
and watched the whole thing straight
through ever it's one of those things
where because
i mean you guys that are maybe the same
age as us like you'll remember back in
the old days like in the early 80s early
to mid 80s um you know the same movies
would be on cable pretty much like all
the time they'd show it'd be like four
or five movies a day and they would just
run them like in succession like in a
loop or whatever
and um
like hbo would have this handful of
movies and they would just play them
over this one month and then they'd
switch out like movies the next month
and so you'd end up seeing a lot of the
same movies kind of over and over again
but you'd be flipping through the
channels and be like oh look it's
superman the movie or oh look it's time
after time or it's grease 2 or it's the
pirate movie or whatever and or it's
arthur that was another one that was on
all the time and um and if it was on
like sometimes it was just the middle of
it but you already seen it kind of so
you're just like man why not we don't
have anything else to watch so you just
like sit there and watch it so you'd
kind of just like see it in pieces
over time like you wouldn't really just
sit there and watch the whole thing you
would just kind of like
see it in pieces over for several days i
kind of feel like that happened a lot
with a lot of movies
um and i think dragon slayer was one of
those
and i don't think i liked it enough to
actually seek out and watch it from the
beginning like i liked it but it wasn't
one that really kind of like
stuck with me what's he saying about the
different eras inside excalibur and
stuff where right the top one
oh okay uh wanted to add that when i
watched excalibur
i always felt the old era was matt was
magic runes and paganism yeah
um the new era was rationalizing it with
religion yeah yeah and and science yeah
yeah because remember
once the round table is established
it shows um what's the name parseval
when he
comes into the kingdom and he's trying
to find his way to the kitchen he goes
through the damn bazaar
and they've got like wise men from the
east with their big horoscopes and star
machines and all these people doing
alchemy
so technology is starting to to come
about too
but yeah it's definitely showing two
different
er two
one world going and a new world coming
and
there's overlap there i was talking
telling assad i was recommending it to
saad a friend of mine who listens to the
show he's in saudi arabia he likes this
kind of stuff but you know being from an
arabic culture
he didn't know about this
this whole angle you know
so
one thing that was weird about it is
that you see christian priests
blessing excalibur
remember when it's in the stone yeah and
keeping it ready so there was and that's
actually i think
authentic really a lot of the barbarians
you're hearing about the romans
complaining about
you know [ __ ]
400 ad
a.d they're actually christians and uh
they're not are orthodox christians like
you would know today
it was uh kind of like a homemade
christianity it was a mixture of
what you would call mysticism
and
christianity at the same time
so there wasn't a conflict there those
conflicts didn't come until much later
until after orthodoxy was established
yeah much more wheeling back in the old
days yeah and we're just like yeah right
suppose so yeah jesus yeah he's good
yeah that's cool thor too the the
vikings were believing in thor and jesus
simultaneously at certain times yeah
just add more stuff on it it's like a
buffet right super fun um rick shaw says
did tom watch kill list i did a review
kill list uh no you did not actually you
might like it though
um
that's if you didn't see it i put up a
review of that yesterday it's a british
crime thriller slash horror movie like
it goes horror direction in the last
third
um that's an excellent excellent movie
2011.
um
man that one scene where he beats that
dude to death with a hammer holy [ __ ] i
have very i have very rarely seen
anything as
brutal as that and it looked
real
i mean you know
it's not like a gory film but it is a
very very violent film and uh i don't
know i kind of feel like it's pretty
well regarded i think but
i think the end of it
which i don't know if i necessarily want
to spoil it i know it's 10 years old but
um
it's better if you don't know
like where the end of it is going
uh but i think the ending kind of like
either people either love it or hate it
so it's one of those things but up to
then it's a crime thriller it's about
two hit men that are you know going down
this thing like they have a contract of
like people they have to rub out and uh
as it goes on
they start to discover that there may be
some larger
kind of thing going on like some kind of
conspiracy sort of thing um you know but
that's all i'm gonna say but yeah it's
actually really really good and like i
said that
man that dude getting beaten after the
hammer that was [ __ ] brutal
holy parish of doom says uh time after
time i haven't seen that one since the
80s god damn it i love
that movie you want that blue ray saw
that movie so many [ __ ] times growing
up i probably you know what if you asked
me to recite the whole thing right now i
probably could yeah i probably could
anybody
if anybody would like to send jenny a
gift of time
we don't have it they don't have it
don't they i thought somebody sent it to
us a long time ago
really
i don't know
yeah go look because i'm not entirely
not in mine they must be in yours okay
but i'll look but i thought i had it but
maybe no maybe not great move i get
confused i have so many um i have so
many movies like so many books i forget
which ones i have no i just i just took
my movies out of the box and there's no
way that's in there because i was
looking for excalibur i ever seen it oh
okay so maybe we don't have it i don't
think i've sworn somebody sent it to us
though i don't think we did like a
couple years back we did a review of it
a long time ago i mean honestly that's
when people ask me
wasn't my favorite movies were from the
early 80s it actually came out in 1979
um but that was one of the movies that i
watched over and over and over again on
cable it was on cable all the [ __ ]
time um and i probably saw it 50 million
times that movie had a fantastic tone to
it the tone was real it was so it's so
good what a great concept yeah for those
you don't know we're talking about
i had a movie that had uh looking the
dude that played the uh
malcolm mcdowell malcolm mcdowell who
was the other guy david warner david
warner and mary senbergen yeah
it's about
h.g wells back in the 1800s he actually
makes a time machine yeah like it works
it works
and jack the ripper gets into it and
escapes into the future in the 1970s
into the 1970s which you know that was
right he doesn't quite have to do it and
the time machine goes back to the 1800s
so h.g wells can get it
get in it and take them he chases him
down so you got h.g wells and
jack the ripper in san francisco
california i believe right now san
francisco right here with him yes
in the 70s and they're having a damn
showdown
and the time machine's there god damn it
it's so good it's so good it's good yeah
like i said it's just it's such a great
concept to start with i mean
h2l's like chasing jack the ripper into
1979.
mcdowell knocks the [ __ ] h.g wells
[ __ ] part out of the park
he's like man that's the way for me when
you when you say h.g wells
it's actually malcolm adele doing that
character this i know i can't like i
can't really separate the two that's how
i see him even though hg wells in real
life like got kind of fat leader so it's
just kind of like so i mean they
actually do show a picture of him later
um you know in the movie yeah uh so
because he comes to like this when he
comes to 1979 he ends up in san
francisco because there's like a museum
exhibit about his life he can get
pictures of himself like older even
though he's only like in his 30s or
whatever
but
it's good because
i like that it has like funny
sort of fish out of water kind of
element to it
um you know because obviously this is hg
wells he's from you know the late 1800s
and he's coming to 1979 so there is kind
of a there is a little bit of a comedic
thing where it's just like oh look at
all this crazy 70s [ __ ] that's going on
yeah and he doesn't understand he kind
of understands it though remember but
yeah woman makes a move on him and he's
like oh free love he's like all right
yes yes free love yes yes but i i like
that they kind of like it's funny but
they underplayed it they didn't do this
kind of like oh my god i don't know how
anything works well because h.g wells
was so ahead of his time yeah that i
like that you know some of the [ __ ] is
like weird but he's just kind of like oh
okay i got you because i know what this
is i got you right you know what i mean
so he kind of like
you know catches up with it pretty quick
he's hot he's hawking um off some
gold and jewelry that he had to try to
get some modern cash so he could spend
some [ __ ] and there's a g the jewish guy
running the damn pawnshop the jewelers
and he has a damn tattoo on his on the
back yeah
and he's like what's that he goes that's
from the second world war
well he says from the war and he says
warren he goes yeah i guess the second
world war and it was like there was two
world world war two i said it's blowing
his mind because
wells
and other i guess you could say he was a
fabian socialist wasn't an english
fabian
they kind of had utopian futuristic
ideas yeah they thought that everything
would progress
along a smooth path and that it would
get more peaceful and
and uh
more civilized and more scientific and
blah blah blah blah progress
well
that was this is one of the best part of
the movies is jack the ripper says oh
yes it's progressed into the world that
is perfect for me
basically what are you saying this is my
world that's a great scene between right
yeah yeah um between h.g wells and jack
the ripper where jack the ripper is
flipping through all this uh you know
channels on the tv and there's just like
wars and just terrible [ __ ]
and he's like 100 years ago what did he
say a hundred years ago i was a freak
yeah you know now
it's like an amateur now i'm an amateur
no one would even notice right um so
right in some ways but i mean you know
it's it's
i i kind of like one way of looking at
it well i mean i kind of like that
they're coming at it from opposing
viewpoints
but from the that point of view 1979
obviously yeah there was a lot of crime
there's a lot of bad [ __ ] happening but
there was a lot of progress that had
been made too so it was just they were
kind of saying that both of them were
wrong because they were kind of at
extreme ends of the right spectrum
although when he showed him all that
wells in that scene is staggered yeah
he's like oh [ __ ] his his faith is
shaking
that yeah i might have been wrong
but it all works out well he says at the
end to mary steenburgen who you know a
modern woman that he meets and falls in
love with um that he says every age is
the same
it's only love that makes any of them
bearable right so he does actually
kind of come to the point of view where
you know i
obviously extrapolating all this utopian
[ __ ] into the future
is not what's gonna happen because
people are just are people you know it
reverts to the mean yeah so but yeah so
it has like a deeper message but it's
still like just a good movie you don't
have to like take that away from it if
you don't want to
um but it's just a really
man it's just so entertaining and just
like i love the acting in it i just love
everything about it and it's just kind
of gory too a little bit for 1979.
that one scene where um where mary steve
bergen's character
comes home to our apartment it's like
covered with blood and there's like a
[ __ ] severed hand laying there that
like used to freak me out when i was a
kid
i can't sandra wants to get something to
eat but she doesn't want to leave
because she might miss something funny
you need to get earbuds and put earbuds
on and just uh go about your business
you could just call door dash or
whatever the german equivalent of
doordash is yeah i mean you guys
probably have something like doors and
we just read doordash right
what's the other one
i got i feel like doordash is the most
famous the most famous one but what said
grubhub that's the other one right i
don't know i used that one before i used
that in st augustine
but i don't know if i'd use it again
because it took forever but i don't you
know
because i was too late
i was in my i was at my airbnb
and i was too [ __ ] lazy to walk like
a [ __ ] quarter of a mile
to get a [ __ ] sandwich
so i kept [ __ ] calling grubhub and
was like bring me bring me a sandwich
and a [ __ ] frozen iced coffee please
and it took like an hour gee maniac said
in german it's just called doordash
[Laughter]
that's funny
victor says wow how old is mary
steinberg and i'm not actually sure
you know what's weird is that tomorrow
or today if you have if you're a patron
i just uh did
a review of a movie called dead of
winter that came out in 1979 which was
mary steenburgen and roddy mcdowell
um and
she was when god so that was um it's
weird because that was 87
which was
what
eight years after time after time and
mary steenburgen looked exactly the same
she didn't look a single year older
i don't know what she looks like now
because i haven't seen in a long time
but
um yeah dead of winter is another one
that i saw on cable a whole bunch
uh growing up and then when i saw it it
was on amazon prime or some [ __ ] like
that i said oh i need to do a review of
that i'll do it in december because i'm
doing all winter movies mostly this
month
and when i went to kind of research it
and look for other reviews [ __ ] nobody
has heard of this [ __ ] movie dead of
winter never heard of it it's a thriller
and it's uh came out in 87 like i said i
remembered it
sort of like i remembered some [ __ ]
about it from back in 87 because it was
on cable a lot
and i didn't realize how far it had
fallen into obscurity
um i had kind of forgotten about it
until i saw it come up like on whatever
streaming platform and i was like oh
it's free and i need to watch that again
cause i haven't seen in a long time and
then when i went to research it looked
for other reviews i found one other
review of it
that was like three minutes long and
they didn't like it and i was just kind
of like
i didn't realize how much that movie had
been forgotten it's it's actually a
pretty decent
film not super believable
but it's a thriller it's a remake of
like a movie from the 40s sort of
but uh yeah so
if you're not a patron then you'll be
able to see it tomorrow i'll put it up
victor says i always think of her as the
mom and step brothers holy [ __ ] was she
in that
i didn't see that movie
was that funny i kind of feel like
that looks like the kind of comedy that
i would think was stupid
but i've had so many people tell me that
that [ __ ] movie was funny that maybe
i'll just like watch it
you know what i'm saying
because i'm really picky about comedies
and a lot of comedies that people like
oh my god this is the funniest thing
ever i'm just kind of like
i don't really like a lot of stupid
humor
um it depends
it can be done well
but
to me it just seemed like like i don't i
don't like that will ferrell kind of
stuff usually
although he's good in um
he was good in elf i liked that he's
good in more serious kind of movies
holy crap what was that [ __ ] movie we
saw with will ferrell in it with where
he was sherlock holmes
oh that was terrible horrible oh my god
i was so
bad i was laughing at the movie it was
just so bad i was so [ __ ] desperate
and i felt so bad for
um
no it wasn't uh people in the theater
john c reilly
because i love john c reilly and he's i
was like dude please i was like you do
you want me to rescue you please let me
get you out of this movie poor john c
riley but um you know because i love him
but i saw that in the theater and people
in the theater were groaning yeah there
was a couple songs i was laughing
okay the only thing grabbed the [ __ ]
queen man and we stuffed her in the
trunk okay that was funny that was funny
that was funny yeah but that was
literally the only funny thing in that
[ __ ] movie
i was just watching that i was just so
embarrassed for everyone of all it was
so try hard god it was just like
like you said it was so desperate they
just like desperately wanted you to
laugh at it it was just so uncomfortable
and it seemed like they knew
it seemed like the actors knew they were
kind of breaking character
through a lot of it it really did seem
like that like that they knew that this
movie [ __ ] sucked you know it's just
it's weird which like i'm willing to
give actors like the benefit of doubt
cause look it's like you know a lot of
them yeah read the script ahead of time
but there are script rewrites during the
filming [ __ ] like that they film [ __ ]
out of order
um you know they film stuff
they do a bunch of takes uh the actors
aren't sure which ones they use
so i kind of feel like actors they don't
even know what the finished movie is
gonna be like really until they kind of
see the rough cut
um you know so i think it's
you know it's easy to like blame actors
or something like that when a movie ends
up being a trash fire
but
i don't know if i'd put the blame there
necessarily because a lot of them just
show up they do their job
um
and they're not entirely sure about how
the
how it's gonna play out like in the
whole in the aggregate you know what i
mean
so i can imagine but that movie that
really really did seem like like you
said
that really did seem like they kind of
knew that it sucked when they were
making it
and we're trying to get through it
yeah it really
that's sort of like don't talk about it
it kind of seemed like that yeah it
seemed like that they were trying to get
through it and they were like
tongue-in-cheek looking at you
going to the audience homes and watson
that's what it was called they were like
they were yeah what are they breaking
into the fourth wall yeah
and they were looking at you like yeah
this [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks i mean i tried
yeah i tried like i said there was a
couple moments in there like i said the
stuff in queen victoria and the trunk
that was funny there was a couple things
in there that kind of made me chuckle
but
i mean honestly i was just like
embarrassed for everyone involved
particularly john c reilly and rebecca
hall they didn't deserve that
um you know what i mean those are
actually really good actors uh i don't
really care about will ferrell because i
don't like most of his stuff because
he's annoying as [ __ ] although i did
like uh stranger than fiction i will say
and i do like elf
but
man
yeah mango said uh yeah holmes and
watson it was dreadful so so bad
i almost want to watch it again no i
don't i almost want to watch it again
just see if it was as bad as i remember
and i think when we reviewed it at the
time because we went you know that was
when we were going to the theater and
doing the matinees so you know we didn't
pay to see it really
um but
i tried to be like positive about it
because i don't want to be one of those
[ __ ] that's just on youtube
whining about everything and complaining
about how [ __ ] everything is because
that's stupid and it's not true
but i was really struggling i was really
struggling like to find something
positive to say about it
um it was bad because man it was just
really really not funny and it's just
really good
it was painful it was just painful
painful to watch so i so i have a bad
i don't know i like a lot of comedies
but
i'm always i mean i'm a horror person
so
if
so i don't really seek out a lot of
comedies
because i always kind of feel like look
i'm gonna watch this and it's supposed
to be funny
and i'm it's you know there's probably
like a 75 chance that i'm not gonna
think it's funny especially if it's like
real dumb like low brow
kind of humor um
or like real lazy kind of humor
um you know i'm usually not about it
because i'm just like
okay whatever um you know like we
haven't seen this done a million times
before i kind of like i like a lot of
british humor like i like a lot of more
like kind of dry sardonic kind of humor
not always
but
i you know i i'm in a more like
something like that i like like black
comedy like someone's like real dark
humor i like that kind of stuff
um
i was kind of gonna say remember that
[ __ ] what was that jim jarmusch uh
zombie movie oh the dead don't die i
know a lot of people hated that but to
be honest i thought that movie was
[ __ ] hilarious
and i think i might be the only person
that thought that well tom liked it too
which i didn't think he would
but when you were to see that movie i
kind of feel like most people just hated
that and thought it was awful
but
for some reason that just i don't know
like the humor in that like really
tickled me i don't really know what it
is so i have a very really weird sense
of humor um which is why i don't seek
out comedies a lot because i feel like
most of the time
i'm just not gonna think it's funny and
i'm gonna be like bummed out
uh danny rolling ghostface says speaking
of funny that new jackass film needs to
hurry up and come out already i've seen
yeah we've seen the trailer for that
that actually looks pretty entertaining
um as much as i said i don't really like
low brow hammer i mean
how can you not love jackass i mean come
on everybody loves jackass i kind of
feel like
um
mango says feral did a good serious
movie called everything must go oh i
haven't seen that worth checking out
okay i do kind of feel like even like
comedians or comedic actors that i find
super annoying like jim carrey
um i can't stand any of his comedies
it's just so over the top and so
frenetic and i'm just like to me that
comes across as like please love me
please love me and it's just like that's
not
that it's really off-putting
um but interestingly jim carrey in
serious roles like he was [ __ ]
fantastic in uh eternal sunshine eternal
sunshine in the spotless mind that was a
[ __ ] great movie i love that so when
he's just playing
a normal person like a normal character
in a dramatic role it's so so much
better because it doesn't have that
whiff of well you know like tom said
desperation about it i feel like there's
some kind of
like please accept me like please think
i'm funny and it's just kind of like
over
it's just over the top and it's just
very very off-putting to me uh victor
says borat is funny yeah i did think
borat was funny uh you know just be fair
holy perishable we've been binge
watching numerous usually bad found
footage flicks on tubie
well if you come up with any good ones
let me know um i'm not a big found
footage
fan
but
there are a lot of good ones i tend to
prefer mockumentaries if you're gonna go
that way but
and i've said this before to be gets
kind of [ __ ] on as like a platform
because it's like oh it's free and
there's [ __ ] tons of stuff on there
um and there's [ __ ] tons of horror on
there and i'll admit that probably like
60 70 of it is awful
um probably you know like shot on a
[ __ ]
phone awful
but
uh there's some really really really
good [ __ ] on there it's just that you
really have to kind of like wade through
a lot of stuff like to get to good stuff
but you know there's but there's a lot
of really good stuff on there too and
it's free you can't complain about it
uh mango says no you're not on your own
i loved it myself jenny so thank you i
thought it was the only person that
actually really likes the dead don't die
i get why people wouldn't like it i get
it um but for whatever reason
just that really really like
dry sense of humor i just thought that
was so so [ __ ] funny yeah tammy said
is that the one with bill murray and
adam driver yeah it's that one
i mean that that repeating gag about the
[ __ ] song and it's just
and i don't normally like self-aware or
self-referential stuff because again it
seems to me too
i don't like stuff that tries too hard
you know what i'm saying like i don't
like stuff that's kind of like look how
meta we are look how clever we are i
don't really like
stuff that calls attention to itself in
that way i'm like just just be
that um and let people draw their own
conclusions but for whatever reason
the meta-ness of that one just like
[ __ ] cracked me up i guess because it
was just so
weird too
i don't know it's kind of hard to say
uh truman show was good yeah truman show
that was another one
that was another one's good you know
what i've hugo mentioned cable guy i
don't think i've ever seen cable guy
um i kept meaning to get around to it i
just never did
um
but you know i'll probably get around to
it one of these days uh yeah saunders
said eternal sunshine was great i know i
love that [ __ ] movie so much i think
i saw the theater when it came out and
then i saw it a couple times
subsequently i really actually it's
probably due for a re-watch man what a
great [ __ ] movie and what a great
again a great concept i love
man i love a good concept like that uh
and it's just so good i just
and jim carrey like surprised me in that
one because i think that was the first
had i seen truman show before that
probably not because i think i saw
eternal sunshine in the theater and then
i saw truman show later like on cable or
i rented it or something so i think that
was actually the first serious role that
i saw jim carrey in and i was like holy
[ __ ] like he can actually
act when he's not acting like a total
[ __ ] spaz burger you know what i mean
uh my name is bruce is a good one
roy says i watched the exorcist the
prequel last night it was okay and
pazuzu was mentioned a lot
interesting idea for the origin but it
didn't have to be made
yeah i kind of wondered about that
because i've kind of had
i've had probably like about 50 of
people saying you know
yeah it's really worth watching and
other 50 of people saying no it's not
worth watching
um
i don't know like i said i kind of feel
like we brought this up on when we were
talking about exorcist 2 the heretic
i feel like the exorcist was just a
beautifully
self-contained
story
it didn't really need to be expanded
upon didn't need to have backstory
didn't need to have anything like that
which
you know as i mentioned exorcist three i
think the reason that i like that one is
just because it's not really a
continuation of the first movie it's
just almost like a like a side quest so
it's like its own thing
um you can watch it without having seen
the original and it won't lose anything
um
but the exorcist as a movie i don't
think it really needed sequels or
prequels or no that was a standalone it
was a standalone story and i think it
probably should have been left there
although look exorcist two is also a
standalone in some some ways
yeah i mean
yeah if we're being honest you don't
really have to have seen the first one
[Laughter]
no i mean the second one is like so
batshit and weird and you know so
[Laughter]
what are they saying is it worth
watching
um no well roy was asking about the uh
the exorcist the prequel okay
now wait okay
weren't there two wasn't there one that
was called exorcist
dominion or no well i don't i don't
remember exercise dominion or exercise
yeah there's been more than one
and honestly i think they're making
another one
okay that's what i heard i don't
remember them
i didn't see them right because
i don't you know i don't know i don't
think i've seen them i don't i don't
really like to [ __ ] on the idea of like
sequels or prequels or something like
that because man they've been doing that
since [ __ ] fiction existed
so i'm not gonna get all [ __ ]
crotchety about it it's just that
i don't know like i said some stories
don't need it you don't need it
and if you over explain [ __ ] like i said
if you do like the exorcist which is
good just leave it the way it is yeah
just leave it
um you don't need the backstory the
demon you don't need it's like oh it's a
demon it's like it doesn't need a
backstory it's just scary [ __ ] scarier
when it's not explained when it's not
over explained one uh two and three i
consider them i consider them to be
standalones you don't need to see even
the first one they're they're kind of
like their their own movie yeah they do
reference other stuff they
but it doesn't even really matter i mean
the third one is more like a crime
thriller which i thought was cool like
it just went in its own direction and
then like uh
some of the other exorcist movies that
have nothing to do with that franchise
just exorcism being the thing some of
them are good
yeah you know watch those two what just
watch them
i don't worry about them the best one is
just exorcist the first one that's not
bonsato
yeah that's right the best one the fact
that that still holds up this many years
later is pretty incredible part of it
was because it was an original
uh the tone of it is right
and it's a classic
now timing had a lot to do with it could
be that the younger person that missed
it they weren't around for that in that
era they may not actually
vibe with that movie much yeah they
might they wouldn't respond to it which
you know like i said you know
it's the same kind of thing with me i'm
not going to watch a movie from you know
the 1940s and it's not going to resonate
with me the same way because the
cultural context is different and i'm
not saying that i don't like a lot of
horror movies from you know from the
early air authorities because i do
but
i'm not gonna appreciate it the same way
that somebody that
was young seeing it because i don't have
the cultural context i wasn't born then
so some things are going to
not resonate with me the same way that
somebody that was alive back then would
yeah and i've heard a lot of people who
know 40s cinema real well they say that
[ __ ] 40s a lot of 40s and 50s [ __ ]
sucked
you know except for cat people and they
put it out they put it out and nobody
really see it and it was quickly
forgotten some movies have been lost
forever
you know
a lot have yeah especially during the
silent era yeah which is a shame i like
silent movies they may not have been
good the ones that were lost though
maybe not but you but we'll never know
will we because they're gone yep gone
um i like a lot of silent movies there's
something like really really creepy and
atmospheric about that era in filmmaking
that i really really dig um i really
like all those like german expressionist
kind of films there's like so weird i
love the visuals in them honestly i saw
this one
it's probably on youtube i think i saw
it or it used to be
it was an adaptation of
the fall of the house of usher i think
it's only it's not long it's only like
an hour maybe not even an hour
and the visuals in it i think it was
1921 and the visuals in it are so
[ __ ] cool oh my god i don't even
remember who made it but it's like super
super cool grant this comes in goes
other topics how to build your own
silencer
new new rock
or giova or gravani boots i don't know
those i never i only
only had new rocks
how to convince a scientologist to walk
away and why the roman empire fell okay
i've always wondered about that about
the scientologist because
this is kind of interesting to me having
worked with scientologists and i'm also
kind of interested in how people
get sucked into cults
because
i don't understand um the mindset of
somebody that could get sucked into a
cult yeah
but like i understand it's not that
uncommon and you know however like they
come at you
most people could get kind of sucked
into a cult whether they think they can
or not so i'm not thinking i'm above
that i'm just saying you'd have to come
at me a different way
but
um that's something that i've kind of i
kind of feel like
in a lot of ways you have to sort of
come at it um i guess it's different for
everybody but you have to kind of come
at it on like on your own
i kind of feel like you have to get to a
place where
enough things build up that you're like
hey this is [ __ ] up
i really need to get the [ __ ] out of
here i don't know if just making fun of
them i think making fun of them
helps
some people uh but then some people
respond better to
you just kind of like being nice to them
but also just kind of like asking
questions like hey isn't it messed up
that you know blah blah blah and like
just making them think about it so they
can come to the conclusion on their own
so i don't know i don't know if there's
like one way yeah but that kind of [ __ ]
fascinates me like people that are that
are like trying to get people out of
cults yeah and like the psychology
behind that i'm really interested in it
okay to answer the question how to build
silencers first of all silencers do not
exist they're [ __ ] sound suppressors
and uh there's no reason for them to be
a controlled item
and they'll eventually legalize them the
reason why sound suppressors ended up
becoming a registered item with the nfa
uh was during the 20s
uh poachers were going out and they were
over hunting
certain animals back during the great
depression and
sound suppressors could hold the noise
down over long distance
so a person could evade a game warden
uh in terms of crime they do not impact
crime at all
you can
pop somebody with an unsuppressed nine
millimeter pistol in a house and the
neighbors will not be alerted to it
um
then you could suppress that same pistol
and pop somebody in the room of a house
and everybody else would know that
something happened they may not be able
to identify it as a shot
but suppressors were never
about hiding the fact that shots had
been fired
all right
there's some exceptions very small
calibers 22s 25s 380s 32s
which are very weak calibers usually in
blowback with a fixed barrel
in some cases you can hide the fact that
a shot has been fired with those
but it really doesn't matter you're just
letting the room next door you're just
hiding it from the room next door it
wouldn't make much difference
if it was a larger caliber and you're
talking about the neighbors you know
what i mean
they just doesn't impact crime really uh
suppressors
so suppressors should not be controlled
um
all they do is reduce the
decibels a suppressed 45 caliber pistol
is still louder than an unsuppressed 22
caliber pistol
so
should you register a 22-caliber pistol
because it's
louder or is it because it's quieter
than a 45 that has been suppressed it
doesn't make any sense everything is all
just
relative you know a suppressor can
reduce some decibels off of it
now anything that's has a projectile
that's [ __ ] ultrasonic it's going to
make a sonic boom it's it's going to
still be loud
if it's a rifle there's a lot of powder
involved in the [ __ ] rifle cars are
just long
um
the velocities are high
suppression is
not realistic you can suppress them but
it doesn't make a big difference if you
ask me
um
the main thing is is that
a suppressed pistol caliber full auto or
semi-auto
firearm
is comfortable to shoot and it's a
little pussycat in terms of the way it
handles
especially indoors you don't have to
worry about hearing protection as much
now making one
you have to ask yourself there's two
questions you have there's a question
you have to ask before you try to make
anything
does the barrel move or not
because
some firearms the barrel
other firearms the barrel does not move
during firing so if you attach a weight
on the end of the barrel you're going to
jam it if it moves
so
a lot of
semi-auto pistols that have slides they
have tipping barrels like nine
millimeters and bigger you know
when you start adding weight on the end
you're gonna [ __ ] up with the cycling
ability and you might have to strengthen
springs so it's not just a suppressor
you have to have a stronger spring now
to close the slide there's a lot of
things about it but the suppressor
itself is easy it's a tube
with baffles in it basically with a hole
going down it and it's just giving
something to expand you're just
expanding and contracting the gases
behind the projectile that's all you're
doing
if you wanted to make something like
that easy you get something like a 22
you get something like a dam
a can of tennis balls cut all those
tennis balls in half and let all the
[ __ ] filling come out of her so now
you have tennis balls
rubber tennis balls
cut in half and a can
take that can
put some damn
brillo pad you know like scrubbing pad
put that in there and then put the half
a damn
rubber tennis ball and then more brillo
pad and more tennis ball brillo pad
tennis ball until you fill the whole
thing up
with half tenant rubber tennis balls and
half the damn brillo pad
take that pop a hole in it stick a
barrel of a rifle in there and tape it
all around in there
when you fire it the bullet will it'll
do what a suppressor does especially 22
or smaller cattle calibers it'll it'll
be quiet
now it'll blow off little pieces of damn
metal [ __ ] from your scrubbing pads
it'll come out any forensic
investigation they'll know that you use
the suppressor you just add if you if
you think that this is going to somehow
help you commit a crime you're wrong
you're leaving more evidence now
okay
anytime this all i'm gonna be slick and
be an assassin with a silencer this is
james bond movie [ __ ] that's not how
it actually works in real life
you'd have a better chance of getting
away with it without the suppressor
because you're not leaving the evidence
behind the more evidence you leave at a
scene
the more you increase the chances that
it will be linked to you
anytime a crime happens and you should
know this by listening to this show
regularly
evidence is left evidence is taken away
that's what happens at a crime scene
evidence from the crime scene ends up on
the offender and he takes it with him
the offender leaves evidence at the
crime scene you have to keep all that
[ __ ] to a minimum
okay
uh professionals that do this [ __ ] for
security companies and [ __ ] kill
people and white people you know [ __ ]
silence [ __ ] witnesses and because
you have security agents
who are hired by elected officials in
other countries who need enemies taking
taken out and their cops and soldiers
ex-cops ex-soldiers ex-private eyes
with have learned everything from mafias
and everything that happens
the main thing is to foil the
investigative process that's what that's
all you're doing which is easy if it's
pre-planned
if it's something that's done at the
drop of a hat it's a lot harder
but that's why first degree murder
carries a light a death sentence or a
life sentence is because it's more
likely to get away with the first degree
because it's all pre-planned that's what
and that's what an assassination is
you know so
first rule of thumb make sure they don't
find the body they don't by the way they
don't find the body
yeah well
[Laughter]
the rule in general is to foil the
investigative process
so you want to deny the investigators as
much as possible you want to deny them
the crime scene
the time of the crime
the victim
the weapon
everything you want all of that obscured
or denied
that and so you and no link that way
nothing can be linked to anything
and that's how serial killers and
assassins and [ __ ] like that have gotten
away with things
sometimes just a dude could just be
lucky you find a dead dude in a car you
don't know who killed that guy this is
the bullet hole in his head
you know and the dude who did it might
have just been an idiot drunk
but you still can't catch him just
because not enough evidence was left at
the scene
and there wasn't enough association
yeah there's no association so that's
less evidence
you're denying evidence to the
investigators
so that's always what it is
now the iceman he denied
the
he denied the investigators the the
crime scene
the time of the crime
not the victim they eventually got the
victim but the victim had a lot of times
have been frozen for a long time you
know
and the weapon
so there's no association they can't
associate it with anything
fourth throw down says don't they say
that a lot of the old celluloid was used
to make shoe soles i had heard that
actually
what happened with a lot of the old
movies was that a lot of them were shot
on that silver nitrate stock right which
is super flammable yeah
so a lot of it just uh spontaneously
combusted sadly
uh roy said and yeah this is actually a
good recommendation another film i
watched was the
oh he's wait where was the thing before
no need for me is he
oh okay good yeah
uh knight of the demon from 1957 really
really good movie if you haven't seen
that one uh based on mr james casting
the runes um is actually like really
really excellent probably actually i
would argue
easily one of the best horror movies in
the 50s easily
uh let's see okay so
i thought we were a cult occult of
pookie
all hill pookie destroyer of worlds
at least destroyer furniture
chewing on everything in here like she
does
um but you know
well let's see okay so i'm trying to
like they're saying if i get my own
channel it'll be bad immediately that's
what sandra said probably
probably
let's see where
now i'm like really behind because i was
like i had some questions i wanted to
answer up there but then like a bunch of
them
kind of uh came and i have to kind of go
to taylor showed up what's up taylor
well hey everybody's here you know why
tila's here tila's here to see the
vanilla gorilla
[Laughter]
yeah roy asked if we reviewed kill bill
we haven't yet i actually really like
that movie though i saw in the theater
uh but we haven't reviewed it yet i
don't think
i haven't seen in a long time now that
i'm thinking about it all right i'm
gonna run to the bathroom go ahead you
talk i'm gonna talk to him
see what everybody's doing tila jumps in
she goes greetings all
happy friday excuse me
will i take a long drag off my drink
okay
yes
tina's laughing over [ __ ] vanilla
gorilla that's right i'm not only not
only vanilla gorilla
the one of a kind tom ross
honky kong honky call
see what's going on with the
no need for me saying [ __ ] vanilla
gorilla that's a new one to me yeah
vanilla gorilla
tina worked with his inspire for matter
of carry too god damn these [ __ ] are
coming down on me they're [ __ ]
dropping all kinds of [ __ ] oh yeah i
[ __ ] up on that one that was a good
one though
i messed up madame curie was hooking uh
like a matari
coach says i'm one cool cat making him
laugh
well it's either vanilla gorilla or
honky kong one of the two
[Laughter]
yeah man mango's going greeting this
christmas nintendo yes we were talking
about nintendo we were talking about
nintendo early on i was thinking about
donkey kong
so i was just like the honky kong that's
right
remember how you make that noise
jump
donkey kong oh
what now is that not only did i come up
with the [ __ ] uh donkey [ __ ]
vanilla gorilla it's honky kong
oh my god
somebody make that video game
immediately honky kong donkey kong yeah
it's got me up at the top
[Laughter]
the barrels are coming i'm throwing back
dude
[Laughter]
i feel like you should be throwing
something other than barrels though
which what would tom be throwing i feel
like you'd maybe i think you should
throw pizzas yeah something like that
you should like throw them like like
barrels honky kong
we need a whole thematic thrust i was
saying we were evil hairless monkeys
[Laughter]
it was all kind of going in here the
vanilla gorilla please tell me something
about the gala gorilla but vanilla
gorilla
you know what's weird i was just
thinking of miguela gorilla today i
haven't thought of that in a really long
time oh i think it's because i was
watching an episode of uh mst and i
think that
pearl called bobo that at some point she
called them magilla and i think that's
what i was thinking of wasn't the one i
watched last night though last night
like you guys to be has 40 bajillion mst
episodes and riff tracks and cinematic
titanic yeah um so i was watching danger
death ray last night i hadn't seen that
one in a long time
so that was super fun which like i said
has one of my favorite lines where
there's this [ __ ] great sea it's like
a spy movie like a really cheap jack um
i think it's italian like james bond
ripoff
and there's these scenes where it's like
a submarine and a helicopter but they're
very obviously toys
i mean really obviously
and uh i just love mike's line it's like
oh the ocean's beautiful in this part of
the tub
[Laughter]
because it's totally like a bathtub full
of water he's saying something about
y'all i was watching foul play last
night oh i love that movie
maybe she said
uh an old comedy tom would have done
well as dudley moore's character in that
movie i can see him trying to seduce
goldie hawn yeah
chubby chase was in that too right
yeah that was like a murder mystery but
like a comedy holy [ __ ] that was another
one that used to be on cable all the
time back in the old days and i think i
saw that one like a zillion times
wait was that the one
okay was that the one with burgess
meredith and he had a python named esme
or is that a different movie please like
remind me
but i'm pretty sure that i saw that like
a bunch of times
saunders says tom can throw his spam
cans yeah that'd work
spam oh and then oh and that's actually
win-win because you could get spam to
like sponsor yeah the video game yeah it
could be like um
yeah spam presents honky kong yeah
yeah
and you have to make it look like the
old one you have to make it like an old
like 80s retro video game yeah holy [ __ ]
yeah
with bald me up there
yeah with no shirt on or no maybe with
your danzig wig dancing wig don't matter
oh my god yeah
if i knew how to like uh design retro
video games i would totally do that
hilarious honestly somebody google has
somebody done honky kong i feel like
they i feel like somebody has probably
done that
if they haven't somebody needs to
maybe maybe everybody remember how the
girl would go baby
yeah yeah yeah
holy [ __ ]
you guys remember burger time yeah that
was bad i liked burger time
like it's a
what a weird [ __ ] concept i don't
even know what they were smoking back
then but yeah that and for some reason i
liked those really weird concept video
games like burger time and joust
you know what i mean it's like yeah i'm
riding an ostrich and i'm just whacking
this other ostrich so it lays an egg
like it doesn't make any sense what do
you think about it but
whatever weird ass video games back then
um
yeah dj maniac says honky kong is
probably a hack some geeks made with a
swapped palette yeah see i can see that
i would be very surprised if somebody
hadn't thought of that oh we weren't red
we weren't red oh no no no
[Laughter]
no i said it a bunch of times oh no come
on please don't don't don't don't no no
no
okay
okay
resurrected all right resurrected we're
saying the h word too much
[Laughter]
i don't know i said it a bunch of times
before it like went [ __ ] and then
okay this is what i'm gonna do we need
to make a shirt
it's called dad
donkey kong yeah well we i need to get a
picture of you i think i probably have
one instead of a picture because you do
[ __ ]
well yeah you can do like i can pixelate
i know how to do that i can do that in
photoshop i just don't know how to like
i don't know how to design a video game
but i can make something look like an
old school video game like just a
picture well just just [ __ ] lift a
picture of the [ __ ] video game up and
just change the face on it
to tom yeah yeah go ahead
yeah right yeah well we throw in a spam
can yeah spam can't come
although we'd have to we'll probably
spam lesus so we probably have to like
think of some other name like
what would be another name for spam that
everybody would know it was spam but you
can't call it spam i don't know hmm
what spam spins for spiced ham right no
i thought it i don't think it stands for
anything i thought it was spiced ham i
thought that was the whole point of why
they named it that spam isn't ham and
it's also not spicy
yeah but i thought i mean i always
thought that's where the name came from
maybe
maybe
i mean so
what could they call it what could they
call it there's no telling where they
got that from because it's not spicy
it's [ __ ] salty
yeah so that's what i was thinking maybe
we could do something with like the salt
content it's pork shoulder but it's not
ham it hasn't been cured
it was just cooked in a dam well it's
ham in the sense that it's a pig yeah
yeah dude oh that reminds me
um somebody i think it was on last
friday's show or the one before
somebody recommended the rift tracks uh
i think it's called this is hormel
uh yeah i totally watched that [ __ ] oh
my god that [ __ ] was hilarious you
probably should need to see it because
it's half an hour long
and it was hormel because they make spam
you know yeah uh among many other things
and this
short
it was i don't know what year it was it
was probably the 50s
but the whole frame story of it if you
want to call it that was these two boys
who for whatever reason because they
didn't have anything better to do i
guess were super fascinated by hormel
and wanted to tour the plant
so they wrote letters to whoever ran the
hormel plant and they let them
tour the plant and they um
in this half hour short
i mean they went there every single like
they show like the cab the the cow
carcasses being skinned like pulling the
skin off and like making the meat
uh you know paste
that they put in like sausages and stuff
like that it's uh
if you're a vegetarian it'll probably
like groce you the [ __ ] out but uh you
know
i guess back in the 50s everybody's just
kind of like ooh
meat meat
i wasn't grossed out that much but
i just thought it was like really funny
because they probably wouldn't show that
nowadays because people like we don't
really want to show like where meat
actually comes from because it's kind of
disgusting this is pretty disgusting
look
i know you people get upset about spam
and i've come on here as an advocate and
of this spam for a long time he's this
advocate yeah i'm a spam advocate
we got cook books and everything i've
made good recommendations on stuff and
you guys would go yeah it's pretty
spam spam
is a is a miracle of modern science okay
it helped the united states win
the second world war
and then after the war it kept the
germans and the japanese alive we fed
them with [ __ ] spam until they could
get back on their feet all right and not
eat spam anymore
[Laughter]
okay did you guys get interim they're
still eating spam on a lot of island
nations are there because you know they
have problems getting meat in places
like hawaii well probably they got a
taste for it too i mean i imagine and
you have to understand
ramen
well you you're eating ramen right how
wonderful and sophisticated and foreign
japanese ramen ramen was basically
designed to be eaten with spam
and cube it up cook it and put it in a
ramen
um and and and ramen itself has no
nutritional value a lot of calories
though a lot of calories and
it is a it isn't it is an eastern type
food
okay but the japanese wanted something
to eat
with that spam that we were giving them
on on government assistance
and they came up with a lot of good
stuff egg you know what i mean they'd
make like basically an egg omelette with
chopped up spam and vegetables and they
they tossed that and then they put it in
a bowl of spam and they they eat that
today
okay
here in the united states you got
hamburgers and french fries in japan
it's it's damn
ramen and half the time with spam in it
the flavored spam that you have now in
the low sodium span is a lot better than
the original ones all right but you
can't eat that [ __ ] right out of the can
you want to slice it like lunch meat or
you want to cube it or you want to break
it up and use it in a recipe that's what
it's for but it's good protein
and it's not mystery meat it's pork
shoulder it's pork shoulder which that's
a
that's a good cut of meat
i mean it's not
it's not tenderloin
but it but it's also not [ __ ] and
snouts like a [ __ ] hot dog is
okay
yeah i still call i still call hot dogs
lips and [ __ ] i think i think i got
that i think i got that from kids in the
hall yeah
anything you can't sell ends up in a
damn hot dog or a sausage that's okay
hot dogs are good though and um so
when you kind of even though i love
sausages you know [ __ ] german
sausages american sausages italian
sausage brazilian sausage as long as
they're not too too like spicy or with
too much of that because like i said
it'll give me heartburn i'm too old for
that but if you compare a can of spam to
a sausage
a can of spam is higher on the hog
literally it's higher up on the hog
it's it's it's it's coming it's it's
pork shoulder
which that's where your taco meat comes
from
that's where your roasts and [ __ ] you
know or
uh uh wait a pulled pork
it's that
the problem with spam is that the
original recipe was too [ __ ] salty
yeah well honestly even the low sodium
nowadays are too salty for me and i'm
not and i like salt
uh i'm not saying that but even the low
sodium ones now are just it's too salty
and it came from a time when i can't eat
pepperoni either so like i said it gives
me heartburn
it's just too much preservative
totally confident in the canning process
and so if you put a bunch of salt in it
you would help preserve it then probably
you won't die if you want to but yeah
you don't need that much salt they
didn't know that back then yeah but the
bacon versions are good there's a bunch
of they have a chorizo flavor
they have a bunch of different flavors
and the price is right it's just you
have to know what to do with it slice it
thin fry it eat it with eggs
put it on a damp sandwich uh you use it
in a you can use it in ramen you can use
it in
the japanese use it in um
sushi rolls
there's a lot of [ __ ] yeah i think i
said that yeah so you can do a lot with
it
and uh hawaiians eat it they barbecue it
eat it with pineapple eat it on a
sandwich make a make a damn hawaiian
barbecue pineapple damn sandwiches and
[ __ ] it's good you know you just have to
be creative with it
and uh but the best thing about it um is
that it doesn't cost a lot of money it
stores forever if the hurricane hits and
you lose power you can still trust that
you can eat the spam um
it's it was the original mre
world war ii
the world war ii uh [ __ ] uh the
english and the american forces were
spam powered that's all they ate spam
and crackers and [ __ ] cheese whiz
and coffee instant coffee and chewing
gum and cigarettes
i mean like i said ridiculous i don't
hate spam if i had to eat it i would but
i don't know for some reason it just
tastes like salt and preservatives
that's all i can taste
even the low sodium one that's all it
tastes like to me it's not much uh
there's not many preservatives in it
it's just it's brine
i think there's mustard in it
uh certain kind of i think there was and
it's it's cooked in the can
under under well yeah see you should
watch that this is
uh you know short that's on
uh
rifftrax because it tells you exactly it
shows you how they make the spam yeah
making cake among many other things
cooking it in the can is the best way to
sanitize it because it's pressure cooked
yeah vacuum builds up it kills
everything and it also makes everything
very very tender so you don't have to
worry you know
and you can and and you can and it's
fast
it doesn't take long
i think the temperature isn't
involved it's it's less than 10 minutes
in it did they say the cooking process i
think they did but i can't remember 10
minutes
now i'm gonna have to rewatch that
because that's incredible for the amount
of meat they're processing
uh coach raylo says scrambled eggs and
tuna is a great comment yeah also good
you know what i don't think i've ever
had that but that sounds really good
i love eggs and i also love fish that's
good
so well [ __ ] now i kind of want that do
we have any tuna
i don't think we i think i got some do
we if you want a good thing with tuna
what you do is you get
you just go get the body f
curry spice mix you can get a big thing
of yellow curry spice mix you can get a
big one for like two bucks okay
you take your can of tuna you drain it
you put the [ __ ] tuna in the bowl you
put about a tablespoon of that curry in
there
and some uh raisins or craisins crazy
they're better yeah craisins might be
better some diced apples diced green
apples green apples all right and some
mayonnaise and stir it
and if you have nuts like almonds and
sugar yeah that too and let it cure for
about an hour and then use it as a
sandwich spread goddamn you will [ __ ]
love it it's good yeah it's a yeah
curry tuna salad jenny loves it i showed
it i love it i showed her that it's real
good i mean anything it's nuts and
apples i kind of feel like it has to
have the nuts and apples in it nuts
apples raisins and curry and a little
craisins are better yeah i don't like
raisins all that much touch of brown
sugar you can use white sugar but just a
ton of sugar you want to get a sugar
salt balance to it yeah but the
mayonnaise
i remember there's a little bit of brown
sugar i think
um
i usually taste it and go that's not
that's not sweet enough that's not so
you want like a sweet salty kind of a
i think i put that in the cookbook
didn't it maybe not um i don't remember
if we did tuna salad or not i don't
think we did
but you can have that with it with with
lettuce and salad and you know
vegetables or yeah sometimes yeah
because sometimes i'll just like throw
some salad fixings into a bowl and then
just like put a glop of that on top of
it or you know that's good too or you
can eat it the sandwich which is also
good like on toasted bread
mmm
now that makes me want some curry tuna
salad oh yeah we haven't had that in a
long time
no now that i'm thinking about it
it's funny i didn't really like i've
loved seafood but i really didn't i
didn't gain an appreciation for tuna
until i got older
i like seafood except tuna for whatever
reason
i guess because it was canned and i have
a thing about canned meats
i don't really like meat that comes out
of a can it tastes weird to me
yeah tina's uh tila saziba put onions in
the tuna salad yes i put finely minced
onions i'd put anything in there but
onions would be good onions would be
good in the in the also in the curry
tuna that i told you about
i would even put like slices of fresh
cucumber on the damn sandwich oh yeah
with the curry and everything so it's a
bunch of stuff you could do to be honest
one of my very favorite like very simple
very cheap sandwiches
is a toasted bagel
cream cheese yeah salt pepper cucumber
slices
delicious
delicious
and not super that many calories locks
yeah i mean that too yeah
yeah somebody's uh teaching a maniac
cooked in the can with bigfoot by chuck
tingle
that's his neck [ __ ] book uh you know
yeah jeffy art says you can put canned
tuna in anything uh yeah pretty much
uh and victor says eggs and fish i've
never thought of mixing those i haven't
either but now
i don't know
i mean i'm kind of intrigued um and
honestly i'll put eggs on
everything i like eggs on hamburgers i
like eggs and ramen we used to put
hard-boiled eggs inside tuna salad all
the time
oh yeah i guess so yeah cause that yeah
that's like a tuna salad egg salad right
egg salad is another thing that i didn't
like growing up
i had yeah i was a really it's strange
because now i'll eat pretty much
anything
but when i was a kid i was a super picky
eater
and i didn't like anything that was like
gloppy
i loved mayonnaise
but
anything that was like chicken salad or
egg salad or something i was just kind
of like ew it was like too much i don't
know why i was like grossed out by the
even though i loved mayonnaise yeah like
i would eat a sandwich with just
mayonnaise on it that's how [ __ ]
weird i was
i would also eat just a stick of butter
tila's asking me she's been having a
craving for tuna casserole to ever make
it i know how to make it i have made it
many times we haven't made it in a long
time though i don't think we made that
for no [ __ ]
you remember nine or ten years remember
betty crocker's tuna helper they had a
bunch of different things that you could
do with the damn tuna
and it would it would be done in a pot i
liked those
um
but you could also take that
make something like that you just have
pasta and then you have your cheese
sauce and you have your tuna or you have
whatever sauce it is you're going to use
and you put that in a damn glass
square pan
and cover the top of
it hold on hold on
cover the top of it either with like um
uh breadcrumbs and butter or um
uh
these those little french's fried onions
you could put those on the top of it and
bake it it'd be
really good remember the little fried
onions are coming again well everybody
buys those now to put them on top of
green bean casseroles thanksgiving you
kind of on top of it
do anybody buy those at any other time
of the year uh i used to just uh [ __ ]
i i mean i gotta just get them and eat
them
yeah they're kind of good just by
themselves yeah i don't even like green
bean casserole honestly
i know that's i know that makes me like
not an american i guess by certain
standards
but
because everybody like thanksgiving
everybody's like ooh green bean
casserole i don't know i don't i don't
love it just saying
i guess i ate it all at this time you
did i didn't i didn't i didn't need a
single bite of it i didn't need any
green bean casserole i didn't eat any
cranberries okay
mostly i'm i'm a turkey potato stuffing
corn girl pumpkin pie
i don't really like green bean casserole
all that much
i don't really like i don't really like
the sweet potatoes with the marshmallows
i'm not down with that i don't really
like it and i just kind of feel like
i'll eat it but that's a lot of calories
yeah and honestly it's like if i'm gonna
eat a lot of calories i'd rather like
have more turkey and more potatoes and
more mayonnaise on my turkey sandwich
and more stuffing i don't really want
like cranberries sandra says she she
mixes fresh tuna with her salad all the
time oh yeah i used to do that also oh
yeah
take make any kind of fantastic salad
with [ __ ] maybe that balsamic vinegar
and [ __ ] olive oil toss it have all
kinds of stuff in there fresh mushrooms
do kind of like an italian seasoning on
top of it you know what i mean with the
you know oregano basil [ __ ] parsley
mixture you know
on there toss it and then put a can of
[ __ ] tuna in there oh man hard-boiled
eggs and then throw a big thing of like
slivered almonds in there yeah well she
likes almonds i i like i like slivered
almonds sometimes i like it because i
like something that's crunchy
i like some crunchy [ __ ] in there yeah
you know what i mean
i just uh
i like a salad i like a salad too yeah
but it's gotta have meat in the salad
chicken or chicken or fish i don't care
about having meat in it but it is good
with tuna in it um
i like egg in it and i like nuts in it
yeah i don't have to have meat in it i
like our hard-boiled eggs sliced in
there put it in there crumbled and then
you could do um
wilted spinach salad fresh spinach
with the the bacon and the vinegar and
you [ __ ] toss that [ __ ] hard-boiled
eggs in it man it's really good
we haven't done a wilted spinach salad
no we haven't you like that yeah okay
yeah i love that [ __ ] i make some i love
that [ __ ] yeah gotta get the bacon
grease i got that good bacon down there
i can do it
anytime i get you mostly when i get uh
spinach i'm gonna make some indian sod
with it i mean that's when we buy
spinach i buy it every now and then just
for salad because i prefer
baby spinach in a salad instead of
lettuce yeah um i just i don't know i
like that better it has more flavor to
me iceberg and uh iceberg lettuce
doesn't taste like anything so i like to
get spinach for salad but if we're
buying spinach we usually buy it because
we're making saag we're making sog
paneer yeah
so and you need like three or four bags
of that [ __ ] big [ __ ] two two of them
big tubs yeah because you have to kind
of like make it into a
you know you grind it all up
um i said wait i want to buy this house
i'm gonna have a damn [ __ ] island to
put in the middle of that kitchen yeah
because i'm sick of not having a damn
island to work on
tila says one meat i always hated was
liver i'm sorry i cannot for some reason
too gamey yeah i'm not a big fan of it
um i don't mind a little bit of it like
you said the the turkey gravy you make
on thanksgiving you put a little bit of
the liver in there
but seasoning it's just so irony tasting
uh i got it i got into it for a while
uh the army would give it to us and it
was like an option and some dudes
wouldn't eat it no dudes would eat it
i'd get a bunch of it because nobody
else was eating it
i mean it's very divisive with a whole
bunch of stuff it's very strong it's
strong
it tastes like iron it tastes like metal
it was beef liver though and it had been
fried
fried beef liver
and there was some gravy on the side and
um
once you you kind of get a taste for it
you're like okay yeah yeah i can i can
do
and it's good with things like
rice with uh
rice with the like campbell soup
mushroom gravy on the damn rice and
[ __ ]
some fried
sliced fried
so white trash oh yeah
well that's what a lot of army food is
yeah i know
and that's why i have laughter food and
white treasure that's why i'm laughing
yeah
yeah cause it's like oh man it's like
well i grew up white trash too it's like
we put cream of mushroom soup on [ __ ]
everything yeah you know what i mean we
made all our red sauce what's that
that's just fancy as [ __ ] put some cream
cream mushroom soup on yes
but uh no that way come on please it's
back it says okay there it goes it's
back okay oh my god stop being a
butthole i know stop losing connection
lost connection for a second it's back
we weren't talking though because as
soon as i saw it go red i was like shut
up a second so we had british cooks with
his a lot of israeli ingredients
and they would send us all kinds of
really good [ __ ] and [ __ ] one day we
had damn lobster day
and
i wish we had a lobster that only
happened like that whole six months we
were there that only happened like twice
and a lot of these [ __ ] dudes in in
a lot of these dudes in the in the
military don't have
don't have a background of eating things
like lobster they would look at that you
know they're like oh man what is that
you know
especially the inner city dudes they're
like you know they're like oh no what is
that a roach it's a big giant that's a
[ __ ] lobster tail man eat it oh no i
don't want that
so
a lot of your southerners you know i
mean [ __ ]
white and white and black and [ __ ]
hispanics [ __ ] knew all about lobster
okay
so we'd have [ __ ]
tables of dudes eating lobsters and all
the other [ __ ] that don't have
the balls to eat the lobsters and the
hey more lobster for me that's all i
would say and the cooks the british
cooks like guys man you got to come eat
this [ __ ] we made we had so many of them
and these guys aren't eating i mean you
so they were just forcing more and more
livestock
each one of us had a whole [ __ ] soup
bowl of melted butter
okay oh man yeah and two plates you had
a plate for your empty [ __ ] shells
and another plate for all the [ __ ]
tails yeah and i must have had [ __ ]
15 [ __ ] lobster tails
they weren't very big they were they
were the the ones are this big yeah
they're
god damn that [ __ ] was good and what was
funny is that i love lobster i started
to get sick of them
i don't think i could ever start i guess
i can't get sick of lobsters
and it doesn't have a super strong
flavor to be honest with you it's not
like like i said it's not like liver
where it's just kind of like it really
hits you in the face with the flavor
it's very mild that's why people like
dip it in butter or you know dip it in
like horseradish or whatever because it
doesn't it's very mild flavor on its own
we gave up on this
on on the forks and knives because we we
had to make time to eat these things we
were just tearing them apart with our
hands taking the whole [ __ ] tail
holding their hand and [ __ ] scooping
it in the bowl and eating like that you
know what i mean
we had enlisted and uh enlisted an
officer alike
on that section of the damn chow hall
just do another tearing up [ __ ]
lobster tails and then you had all these
other guys these non-lobster
[ __ ] in the other tables go man
y'all are nasty man i can smell that
from here well like i said more for me
more for
us finally
the british cooks just kept bringing us
more and more of it
yeah keep it coming here
keep eating keep eating i have keep it
coming we don't want to throw these out
we cooked we thought you guys oh i'll
eat them all yeah they were like oh
like each one of us like 15 [ __ ]
tails
i was just [ __ ] stuffed i could
totally do that i left with challenge
except i left with lobsters in a [ __ ]
bag mm-hmm
yeah but you weren't supposed to do well
but they're like here you take it
they're really gonna take this yeah if
they're gonna throw it away yeah
thank you jeffy art
i like your little like [ __ ] little
workout pair there a little word
workout pear
victor says liver is gross it is kinda i
mean it's just it has a very very very
strong flavor you either love it or you
hate it
it's okay if like a little bit of it is
mixed into
something like gravy or something but
eating it by itself like my grandma
would do it and everybody's just kind of
like
yeah
man
she ate [ __ ] she ate [ __ ] calves
brains and eggs too though so
tina and and uh uh who is that granters
are in there fighting over lobsters yeah
it's the seized cockroach but i don't
give a [ __ ] that thing's i'm i'm i'm
just i'm gonna steal those teeth i don't
even know they are [ __ ] delicious
they've got a delicious light flavor to
them
the texture is beautiful it's just this
buttery
pop explosion in your mouth
eating those things
and last time we had it was just a
couple weeks back we went to red lobster
and they wanted so much for those things
they were good but i'm like i was
thinking man in the army they'd give me
a whole [ __ ] plate of like 10 of
these we can't even get rid of these
yeah
tila says i wasn't raised on green bean
casserole my husband's family makes that
yeah i usually bring collard greens to
their dinner oh that'd be good i think i
would like that better i'm not i'm not a
big fan of green bean casserole i know
it's like a very opposite i guess it's
more midwestern and southern yeah um i
don't love it yeah i'll eat it but it's
just it's gloppy i don't like a lot of
gloppy collard greens is good uh also um
i'm a big fan of um
uh what do you call it damn things
uh i don't know [ __ ]
brussels sprouts
those are good if you roast them [ __ ]
love them
[ __ ] love bruh don't boil them though
because it'll just make your whole house
smell like farts and they don't taste
that good but if you roast them they are
divine i like them either way they just
have a lot of they just i like them
steamed brussels sprouts with butter
or you could like fry them with bacon
fat that's true that's that's good too
and saunders says uh feta feta on salad
is great too i agree uh feta cheese is
very very what i've been experimenting
with though
i've been experimenting i've been giving
it to jenny
making frittatas
you know we just had one this morning
and you know what i had inside that
frittata cottage cheese yeah it worked
good it was pretty yeah it was pretty
good the moisture boils off and you have
these little tiny
clumps of cottage cheese like feta but
without much flavor but it's more
protein
and they had a real good deal on cottage
cheese and i was like i could do
something with that
so i just been putting it in frittatas
i mean frittatas are like yeah they're
good
yeah frittata with uh
uh georgia sausages sliced real thin
fresh sauteed mushrooms and um
it had sausage peppers yeah sausage
peppers and mushrooms and like bell
peppers and bell peppers i didn't have
i didn't have any spinach or how to put
that in there gotta put that too was
there tomatoes in it no
okay and then i just put a
large very large serving spoon full of
of um
cottage cheese in it kind of spread it
out then i poured the eggs on it and
just let it sit there it turned out
really good actually i thought it was
good it was really good then i seasoned
it with uh goya
that goya spanish
seasoned salt
and a little and pepper
yeah yeah it was good yeah
tila says sandra believe it or not there
are peeps in the u.s south who really
like chicken feet
yeah the chinese like them too
yeah yeah
yeah um i gotta say though tila that's
that's very ebony chicken feet
yeah
and then turkey necks my dad would love
them my dad would love them
[Laughter]
there's not much meat on them
yeah that's what some people were saying
there's not much beetle and uh somebody
like later said yeah pickled pig's feet
always sounded kind of gross honestly
the 7-eleven yeah that was next my dad
loves them yeah that was next to my
grandma's house or behind my grandma's
house they always had like a huge big
jar a pickled pig's feet
and pickled eggs yeah like on the
counter the eggs aren't that bad yeah
yeah eggs it's just eggs it's a
hard-boiled egg they pickle it yeah i
don't i i'm down with that i love eggs
but pickled pig's feet not so much i
never saw a single person buying them
although um my grandma loved those
though oh my dad loved them and my dad
here go ahead he wouldn't have he'd give
me another one he did
eat that you're like
they're just so goddamn sour that
doesn't taste like meat
you're pulling stuff chewy stuff off of
a bone and trying to chew it it's very
it's like a pickle sausage like that
there's not much to it here my dad's
like this guy class you know he's like
he's like that he's
he's i bought it out of a jar at a
convenience store
that's super classy yeah
at the damn gas station yeah at the gas
station hey dad
you got a long way to go
that's about as classy as that red
underwear that's rolled up like a rose
that they sell at gas stations for
valentine's
smell good don't it
just throw it out the window
throwing bones out the window [ __ ] it's
biodegradable that
birds will get it that was like you and
your uh boudin ball yeah like boudin
yeah that's the mississippi [ __ ] you're
trying to get somewhere and i was
thinking man i forgot to eat so you got
these gas stations everywhere you
and that's just the way it was we got
one up the street here there's people
eating out of that damn circle okay
right here although convenience stores
nowadays have come up they're a lot
better yeah i mean now you can actually
get real
edible food in convenience stores who
knew what's funny is that uh in some
cases depending on what you're comparing
it to
you can get a better meal dollar for
dollar out of a damn 7-eleven or a
circle k than you can on some of these
greasy spoons that are at the side of
the road well
i mean to be honest with you it's not
that bad it's pretty good yeah i mean i
worked at a a print shop that was like
across the parking lot from a 7-eleven
so sometimes you know if i forgot to
bring a sandwich or something like that
i'd like you know toddle over to
7-eleven on my lunch hour
and they had a perfectly respectable
selection of fresh salads uh fresh
sandwiches
um they had like little plates with like
nuts and cheese and
little apple pieces and [ __ ] like that
so they had a lot of like really good
options also i have to say 7-elevens
coffee pretty [ __ ] good they're iced
coffee pretty [ __ ] good they had some
weird-ass flavors going in there
sometimes
uh looking at you bananas foster what
the [ __ ] yeah um but
honestly um of all the convenience store
and
you know to an extent fast food coffees
7-elevens got some pretty [ __ ] good
coffee somebody's asking a question down
there where is then we got it there we
go got super chat oh thank you again
jeffy quick question where did tom get
those awesome boots i'm trying to find
myself a pair online are those your uh
yeah these are new rocks okay your new
rocks ones yeah these are spanish
boots
company called new rock
and uh most your rock stars and [ __ ]
motorcycle guys will wear them um
these are the tall ones
and
you're gonna pay you're about 350. yeah
i think that's about 300 or something
like this but you've had those i've had
the thing is you buy one pair and they
last forever i've got two pairs of them
my other
pair of shoes and
they're 20 years old easily
and they look brand new it's all
high quality material and real like
leather i think it might even be horse
hide it's something i don't know it
might be a cowhide it's very thick
whatever it is
and
um this is called new rock
shoes it's probably what you could
probably google that and you start
looking at their boots
and each year they have new stuff
you um
you're gonna see weird [ __ ] like a bunch
of metal spikes bunch of weird
laces uh different kinds of buckles you
want to kind of in my experience you
kind of want to keep it simple when it
comes it comes to new rocks thank you
tila things will tend to fall off over
time on those real complicated ones
uh okay wait what'd you say that fight
club review was amazing amazing movie
thank you very much yeah that's an
awesome movie somebody mentioned us up
above too but we missed it
scroll up also well dj maniac said if
you're on a budget and can't afford new
rocks i recommend demonias instead yeah
yeah i have a bunch of pairs of demonias
they're gonna run you
about a hundred depending on what they
are right um and they'll last a while
they don't last as long as new rocks but
you know they're cheaper
uh rocks can be repaired
demonias cannot demand yeah demonia is
like you wear them for a year or two and
then you just throw them away and you
buy another bear you know what i mean so
i mean some of them it depends the flats
or the flats or the um the lower shoes
that are not boots are usually like 60
to 90. yeah uh and then the boots are
kind of like 100 to 150. you go with new
rock you'll be in good company because
all your heavy metal dudes [ __ ] wear
those
rob halford has pairs of them i've seen
[ __ ]
uh rob halford wearing them i've seen
all your damn
real hard metal band slayer and [ __ ]
they're wearing that they wear new rock
yeah and like i said they are very
expensive but they're really well made
and they if you buy a pair they will
last forever forever pretty much now
like i said some of the ones that are
highly dressed up with lots of stuff on
them those little things fall off over
time
the the ones that are look cool that
have less on them you know i mean like
the ones that i have that are just
buckles down the sides a little more
simple ones they'll last a lot longer
they're a little more robust
and they're they're really good for
motorcycles too they are motorcycle
boots basically they're they're they're
copied after 1960s road racing boots but
then they'll put big heavy platforms on
them which is kind of like what a stunt
boot or a cro or what a cruiser boot
would have and then have big metal
bumpers on the front in the back
uh there's guys that modified them with
[ __ ] flints on the bottom so you put
your foot down on the ground they'll
make a bunch of sparks when you're
riding you know there's a bunch of
different tricks you could do with them
dj maniac says demonias can be repaired
you have to find a patient cobbler is
all i've had it done not gonna lie okay
all right well yeah
most of mine i think that like the ones
that i wore i danced in them so much
that like [ __ ] just started falling off
and i was just kind of like oh well i'm
just gonna get another bear yeah the
problems with demonies for me was always
not really with her it was the soul
falling off with me it was always the
the high
gloss vinyl starting to flake yeah
so they're not high gloss anymore it's
just some kind of a damp
weird synthetic material underneath it
like a mesh looking [ __ ]
because they're kind of patent leather
and over time that starts to kind of
buckle and fall off in in flakes that's
what i meant by they can't be repaired
because it's not leather
it's vinyl yeah i mean if the soles fall
off uh yeah you can get that repaired
all right granthar's astral he he asked
some more oh [ __ ]
okay he has some more questions earlier
but uh he asked more questions there but
he has some questions earlier he asked
what favorite breakfast cereal
breakfast favorite breakfast cereal
actually i like lucky charms actually
and and so yeah i only like the
marshmallows i like uh frosted flakes
but i like ones that are that have more
[ __ ] in them so i like honey bunches of
oats yeah uh back in the old days i
don't think they make these anymore when
i was a kid my favorite cereal in the
whole world was waffles i remember this
which was like were maple flavored and
they were like super crunchy
um
and they tried they did some other ones
like later on that were kind of like
that but it wasn't quite the same
i like um if you're gonna do i like
frosted flakes but
i don't like cereal that gets too goopy
in milk i like it that like maintains
its structural integrity
and i like stuff that has a bunch of
stuff in it so like honey bunches of
oats is good because it has slivered
almonds and those like chunks of granola
but the flakes are kind of
not really that
robust uh but overall it's good if you
eat it quick i just don't like it to get
soggy
uh i'm a big fan of captain crunch
no crunch berries though i don't like
the crunch berries and i don't like that
chocolatey [ __ ] they put in there i just
like the plain ones
um i used to like cookie crisp back in
the old days it's probably too sweet for
me nowadays
but grandpa's asking other questions
that's what i said well that reminded me
like earlier that he had some stuff
earlier
[Laughter]
what did he ask this time well they're
saying the fight club uh victor who was
it hugo's saying that the fight club
review was great thank you pretty much
um
dj uh
grampur's one other other topics why the
south lost the war why people in georgia
my dad does that
yeah that's a very southern thing who
would win a cage match russian specs
nasa versus dave
versus navy what's that div gru i don't
know what that is
how to make women listen and obey okay
if you want we're not gonna obey [ __ ]
off with you first of all if you wanna
learn how to make women to listen and
obey you gotta ris listening to an old
african-american
author named iceberg slam okay go
[ __ ] read some iceberg slam novels
[Laughter]
he'll tell you all about how to make a
[ __ ] woman listen all right
um we're not going to listen yeah
okay well you don't listen to me so why
should i listen to you
[Laughter]
you have to you have to be
high up on your pimp game to understand
to
make a [ __ ] listen
all right go go
go [ __ ] study dolomite
master dolomite all right he'll tell you
all about it okay um
now uh what was the other one the cr i
don't know
i don't know the matchup between uh
spets knots and navy whatever i've never
heard those those guys i gotta peek and
hold them okay
um the other one is why did the south
lose
okay
the civil war that last civil the uh
the civil we call it the civil war the
american civil war it wasn't really a
civil war
it's just been called that it was
actually a war between states
a war of
secession uh states were leaving the
union and trying to form a new union
the reason why the south lost
that one is because
of the mentality of
of leadership of the time of the time it
was conventional warfare mostly
and in those days
a war was kind of like based on
something like chess if you took if you
took the king then you won
if you took a city then you won
people agreed it was like it was like a
game
when an army took ground and captured a
city
the enemy army would say okay you won
and we surrendered it was more like a
a very conventional warfare it was
almost like sports
the south lost because it was fighting a
conventional war and it tried to win
with honor
because there's honor and conventional
war and they're thinking this is very
european-style thinking all right it's
not m and it's also not modern
real war is not conventional war real
war is a symmetrical war
which is
what you would call today terrorism
and really what it is is that you
just continue to resist and to resist
and to resist until somebody gives up
where it's a it's a battle of will
willpower
and the examples i point you towards or
like every major war after
the korean conflict
was an asymmetrical war and or an
unconventional war and we lost them all
of them basically the only one i think
that we won was the panama invasion
uh that one and uh also uh the island of
granada
even though you might want to say that
those weren't conventional
the way the soviet went down
the south lost because it agreed that it
lost that's why
had they said no and just continued to
resist and
done things that say like the vietnamese
did
or you do things kind of like um
like the taliban had done eventually and
and and you do things that the american
colonial army did
to the um
uh to the british eventually the north
would have left the south alone
because it's just not worth the money um
you lose a war when you say you lost
it's like an agreement
it's crazy
for example
so what
china defeats our conventional army they
come into the united states they start
taking over all the damn uh uh
institutions they start making all the
americans obey the chinese way
the americans obey the chinese way we
lost
but if the americans don't obey the
chinese wage ah [ __ ] you we're not doing
this and then now you got to kill us all
but and there's just constant unrest
eventually the chinese go oh [ __ ] it
then you you guys don't want to be
communist
[ __ ] it we're out of here it's going to
cost too much money and then they leave
and then you win which that's what we
did to the british
warfare really doesn't have anything to
do with these damn trinkets or these
generals or any this conventional
[ __ ]
it's more of a game kind of like [ __ ]
chess you know
really what warfare is is just not
giving up
and we got our asses beaten by
the vietnamese and
even the damn
the iraqis to a certain extent and the
afghanis because they don't give up
we can do kill them all
if you kill them all then you're gonna
be they're gonna say well this is
genocide you destroyed their culture you
destroyed other people
so that's how you win you just don't
give up you just continue to say no
we're not gonna do it nope
i would prefer not to nope like for not
to do it like bart'll be the scrivener
yeah
so
all this [ __ ] you hear people
talking about we have laser beams and
[ __ ] jets and [ __ ] yeah well what
good did that do us against vietnam or
afghanistan or those are all just
trinkets those are all
that's all [ __ ] those are all
conventional weapons they're used to
neutralize the conventional army so you
can get inside somebody else's country
and then once you're in there you're
expecting them to obey you and that
doesn't happen
it just doesn't
okay so that kind of warfare is a
failure it doesn't work
real warfare is basically tribal and
that's what apocalypse now is about
apocalypse what i'm telling you is not
new i had to see it myself personally
have been doing that for a living but
now i [ __ ] totally understand what
apocalypse now is about
okay
that
warfare was really about cutting
children's arms off because you
inoculated them
that's what [ __ ] colonel kurt said it
is that's what it's really about it's
just no no
and no is the [ __ ] super weapon that
always wins
okay that's all i'm gonna say about okay
i'm going back to the serial question
because there was some [ __ ] that i
forgot while i was in the bathroom uh
tila says i grew up loving frosted mini
wheats oh my god they're good i still
love frosted milk i like the big ones
too not the mini ones but the big yeah
the big ones are the big ones
um frosted on one side well they're just
well they're not many
it's called are they just frosted wheats
yeah i think it was just called frosted
big [ __ ] are they called they were good
yeah like they're great in your bowl and
that's a whole bowl put the milk on yeah
those are super good remember they had
the black dude on the on the front with
his [ __ ] chef's hat
that was in front of him no
that was a cream of wheat that was the
cream of weekend
was the cream that was a cream of
weekend okay the korean wheat guy yeah
because i used to like cream wheat too
when i was growing up i still like
frosted mini wheats i don't buy them
honestly i don't buy that much cereal we
have
oatmeal
yeah um
we buy those big flavor packs from sam's
that have cinnamon
apple cinnamon and maple and brown sugar
because i like that so i have that for
breakfast sometimes honestly most of the
time i don't eat breakfast gotta tell
you
um you know i do like cereal i just
never buy it tila sent us some money
lord haiti says what's your favorite
cheese
[Laughter]
thank you tila
uh i don't know paneer
mozzarella there's just some cream
cheese all cheese is good honestly
cheese is good i don't think i've ever
eaten a cheese that i didn't like all
cheese is good all cheese has an
application mm-hmm
uh i want to know from everyone what
movie performances by an actress or
actor blew your ass away but underrated
no accolades given ooh
that's kind of awesome
brad dora from [ __ ] uh uh exorcist
three
that [ __ ] act not a lot of people
talk about that movie and it's so
[ __ ] good it's so good and brad dorf
yeah he's one of those guys that every
time he's in a movie you're like ah
we're in safe hands now because brad
dwarf is so [ __ ] awesome
even when he's in shitty movies yeah
like he was in kind of the kind of
shitty stephen king adaptation graveyard
shift it wasn't shitty but it wasn't
great
but man he elevated that [ __ ] he was he
also had a a movie that was kind of like
um terminator slash predator
that he elevated the [ __ ] out of it what
was it called
uh i've only seen clips from it
everybody says it's [ __ ] great i want
to get it
oh no
no what's it called robot or
some [ __ ] like has some random
generic accident
and i've seen clips of him just [ __ ]
chewing up the [ __ ] scenery and he's
like the only celebrity in that movie
it's about some giant ugly looking robot
with teeth
eating people up in a oh i know what
you're talking about um what the [ __ ]
was the name of that [ __ ]
yeah they say that movie that movie is
forgotten and it's great because of brad
well like i said every movie that brad
is in is great because of brad yeah we
love you brad dwarf yeah
honestly i know he's like famous because
of like he's the voice of chucky and
everything
but to me he was in
so many movies that if he wasn't in them
would have just been like forgettable
pieces of [ __ ] but because he was in
them he just like made them awesome to
me and i love actors like that to me he
will always be mentat piper vereese for
the [ __ ] harkonnens and i just like
that [ __ ] just
slam dunk that [ __ ] that creepy [ __ ]
he was [ __ ] he was good he's real
good i have a lot of respect for actors
i especially like and i was thinking
about this earlier in the context of
because somebody was talking about a
movie that elijah wood had done i think
it was come to daddy which is an
excellent movie by the way if you
haven't seen it we did a matinee on a
while back
um
an actor that made pretty much all the
money because he was in like the lord of
the rings movies
and then after that he's like [ __ ] it
i'm just gonna be in like a bunch of
weird ass indie movies like i want to be
in and i really think that's awesome
like you know because you could just be
like in another boring ass tila said i
called it brad dwarf i mean he's like i
love him i love him
no you never he he's not a headliner
okay
they never [ __ ] really put him to the
forefront
but fans know
when they see him they're like okay
all right [ __ ] brad's at this
and he yeah
this is totally worth watching
yeah brad was the [ __ ]
i mean well why is he still here
yeah he's around i'm just talking about
his past work yeah [ __ ] yeah mango says
doug mcclure and humanoids from the deep
oh that's another good pick
i like i like doug mcclure um
he's kind of a cheese dick but
in in a in the best possible way you
know what i mean he was in all those
kind of like
uh
was like journey to center the earth
type of movies what was that one with
where they like had that real phallic
uh ship and they like went down to the
middle of the earth and [ __ ] uh
caroline monroe was in it yeah i love
that movie caroline monroe that's
another one that we're not gonna i could
do a whole episode on caroline monroe
and my
growing up being in love with caroline
monroe and [ __ ] how amazing that
woman
was and how she looked through the eyes
of a seven-year-old boy
who went to who got taken to the movie
theaters by kimmy
his babysitter who looked just like
princess leia all right it was it was
hog heaven but that movie was called
at earth's core there you go at earth's
core i said i know it's not journey or
british something like that badass
british flick it was it was good at
earth peter cushing was in here
yeah peter cushing was in his hair yeah
and carolyn monroe
and her cleavage were in the movie well
i kind of feel like whenever caroline
monroe is in it it's just that's
unspoken that also and her cleavage
also starring caroline's cleavage yeah
she was in freaking it's just it's it
you know it's it's a double act yeah
they go along with yeah they all go
along with she was in a star crash too
and the cleavage was in there [ __ ]
through the whole goddamn movie
star crash is just so interesting
because that had that [ __ ]
yeah it yeah it's very bad yeah it's
terrible but it's also like entertaining
yeah um it also had that guy what the
[ __ ] is that dude's name with like the
[ __ ]
william cat hair
that um
i'll think of it in a minute but he was
kind of like a was he some kind of
evangelist or something like that
and then he was in movies the [ __ ] was
that dude's name
marjo gortner that's what i knew i'd
think of it in a second i knew it was
like some weird ass name marjo gordoner
uh yeah he was in that with his william
cat hair looking like the greatest
american hero
uh so you know
i think i need another drink actually
okay
um brad dwarf played a serial killer in
an x-files episode good stuff says rick
shaw yeah i mean any
i just like i said i love actors like
that and in a way it kind of bums me out
for them because
um
there's a lot of actors that i like that
are kind of like character actors
i tend not to like like big movie star
type actors because they
once you get to a certain level of fame
like tom cruise i know i bring this up a
lot
but you're in a movie no one's gonna see
you as the character you're playing
they're just gonna see oh it's tom
cruise or oh whatever or oh it's brad
pitt or whatever even though brad pitt
is actually
has been in some interesting movies and
is actually like a good actor which you
know he was great in [ __ ] fight club
and i kind of forgot that that was brad
pitt to be honest with you
so uh but i really like i prefer actors
that can kind of more disappear into
their roles like you still know who they
are
but
just their very presence
elevates the movie and like i said brad
dwarf is a really good example of that
because
you never think like he never comes to
your mind i guess when you're thinking
about
oh actors that'll be in the movie but
whenever you see him in the [ __ ] he's
like oh yeah yeah
that's the [ __ ] right there he's like
just making everything better i mean
you know kind of like same thing with
like jeffrey combs like somebody like
jeffrey combs
where
you know you never think of him as like
a leading man or anything like that but
every time you see him in a movie he's
always like really really good and
really interesting to watch
and i'm kind of more into people like
that i'm kind of like i like the
interesting actors
rather than the kind of like
famous a-list
like i said you get to a certain level
of fame
you can't really be an actor anymore
you're more like a star
you can't really be an actor because you
can't disappear into a role anymore
because everybody knows who the [ __ ] you
are you know what i'm saying so you know
i kind of have a lot more respect for
like character actors and like i said i
i have a lot more respect too for actors
that
don't really give a [ __ ]
i mean i guess you know in a lot of ways
like somebody like elijah wood like he
made all the [ __ ] money like with the
lord of the rings movies so he could
just basically say [ __ ] it i can just do
whatever movie i want but
that's awesome though that he's just
like i'm set now i just want to do stuff
that's
fun or stuff that's interesting to me or
stuff that's challenging or whatever
rather than just like pursuing more
money so i think that's like that's
really cool so i like when that happens
uh mango says
margo kidder and superman uh and also uh
john saxon and uh yeah john saxon i was
thinking a bit about the other day
because man he's been in so many [ __ ]
movies he was in a lot of italian movies
as well
um yeah he was in nightmare and i'm
treating stuff like that but he was also
in
mitchell did you guys see mitchell with
judon baker
which was the last joel episode of mst
mitchell
uh yeah john saxon was in that too
and honestly i kind of love john saxon
and then oh pokey yeah look pooky's
gonna be on the show yay there she is
not fooky pants hi baby girl
she's like yep just putting up with it
did she put something
she loves that [ __ ] she does she loves
that [ __ ]
she was like she's been really weird
like earlier today i opened
the bathroom door and she was like down
the hall
and she suddenly came running at me
going
yeah making her [ __ ] and i was just
kind of like oh my god what the [ __ ] is
she's funny yeah
yesterday morning this is really weird
yesterday morning for some reason i
don't really know why
uh the power suddenly went out
like i don't know why it wasn't storming
or anything like that like the power
went out
and i was just kind of like okay
whatever so it got like super dark in
here man pookie was like freaking out
because she has a little water fountain
like right out there
by the door of my office
and it plugs in because like you know
the little water is constantly running
like into the little pool
and she was totally
weirded out by the fact that the water
had stopped running
and was trying to get me to explain to
her
what was going on
because
the water stops running and then she
comes up to me she's like
like she was like that
and she and then she ran over to the
water fountain like looking at it go
like what the [ __ ] the water isn't
reading anymore i was like i know pookie
i don't know what to do it's like that
bro she thought it broke and she was
just like oh my god what's going
something bad's going on it was like so
funny that she was just like explain it
explain it
t brings up some good ones so nobody
really talked about the performances out
of the lighthouse
[ __ ] those day that was a really good
movie
i wouldn't watch it again
but i was [ __ ] oh my god so [ __ ]
so funny saw it in the theater like what
the [ __ ] is going on robert pattinson
that's another guy that he's going to be
the new batman
um
and that's another guy he was in the
twilight movies so a lot of people [ __ ]
on him because of that but honestly
since he was in the twilight movies and
probably like
made like 50 bajillion dollars and now
he'll just be in like a bunch of weird
indie [ __ ] yeah which is awesome i know
and he's a good actor another one that's
that t brought up was adam sandler and
uncut gems a [ __ ] masterpiece
god that movie was so good i have never
been as tense as i've ever like i was
that was one of the most like [ __ ]
nail-biting tense movies sandler's best
movie if you guys haven't seen that one
see that one it's about
basically a jewish gangster down in the
damn
diamond district [ __ ] of new york
pulling all kinds of scams and [ __ ]
around with other people's money all
right and
it's just a [ __ ] iconic flick as
sandler knocks it out of the park and
hollywood [ __ ] booed him for that
[ __ ]
i guess they thought it was anti-semitic
or something but he [ __ ] came in
there was like [ __ ] you i did that [ __ ]
well i i kind of feel like a lot of
people uh were mad that that wasn't man
that was a [ __ ] badass movie he
[ __ ] well wasn't it nominated though
i kind of feel like was it oh yeah i
thought it was nominated i thought it
was it just didn't win but you know the
academy always gets it wrong uh well not
always every now and then they get it
right but
man sometimes
i'm still mad about like some of the
[ __ ] that's won
i'm trying to think of like wha wha what
was the one that like uh what was that
one year
that that movie was it i don't know was
it forrest gump that won over pulp
fiction that everybody's mad about
i'm still kind of mad about that
that was 94 right yeah i feel like that
was 94.
because forrest gump was just like
i kind of liked it when it came out but
i was like
in subsequent years i'm like oh my god
that's like so [ __ ] boomer wanky it's
like i'm just like not even
pulp fiction obviously much better
actually there were a lot of better
movies that came out that year so you
know
than that one
but
honestly if you guys uh one youtube
channel i really like is uh
dom noble and he does a thing called
lost an adaptation where he talks about
movie to book adaptations and what you
know what they changed what's the same
um you know it kind of talks about how
well it worked and he did a forrest gump
one and i had forgotten i read the
forrest gump book like a long time ago i
remember like not liking it i didn't buy
it or nothing i just like found it
laying around somewhere and because i'll
read anything i'm just kind of like okay
i'm bored and like i'll
pick it up and read it and uh i remember
that book
is
bad [ __ ] insane all kind of crazy [ __ ]
happens in that book that they
probably wisely
uh didn't put in the movie
um but it was nice to be reminded of how
[ __ ] stupid that book was
but yeah so
that's the one i remember i remember
everybody being pissed pissed off that
forrest gump had won
that year instead of pulp fiction or
what else was nominated that year
um
was the usual suspects that year
somebody remind me that was 94 right i
mean
also a better film than forest i mean i
kind of feel like all the movies that
were
i mean i'm happy that parasite won last
time because i think that actually was
the best move although i wouldn't have
been mad if uncut gems had one because
that was that was a [ __ ] brilliant
ass movie that was a brilliant [ __ ]
movie
thank you no need for me too got first
photos of paint being sanded off night
69 fastback so happy awesome
um victor says i'm going to start house
of leaves again soon i gave myself
two weeks which is a long time for me
to reread it because like i said that's
one of the books that you can't just
like take it lately oh i'm just gonna
like read it in an afternoon or whatever
you really have to like [ __ ]
immerse yourself in it and like get
involved
it's a very interactive
experience
so
i
you know it's
man it's it's just such a weird ass
i i just salute [ __ ]
mark danielski for coming up with that
[ __ ] because people are still talking
about the [ __ ]
yeah i got that way behind okay i'm not
way behind okay i got that already you
weren't even in here no i'm not in here
i'm coming up here to clean up the mess
to make sure that we're he he assumes
that i had a mess because he wasn't
anything in here
yeah i've never seen everybody saying
i've been keeping up with stuff okay
um
yeah zach says i stopped watching the
oscars after hereditary got zilch and
i'm still mad uh yeah i mean i kind of
feel like at least
at least
best actress should have been
um
i know and i i wasn't expecting it
because the academy they're very very
they don't they still even in this day
and age
they still kind of [ __ ] on horror movies
i don't worry about i don't [ __ ] the
academy no well that's what i'm saying
but it's just i'm just saying that
that's kind of what people are saying is
that it's not really kept up with
people's understanding of movies because
i kind of feel like yeah we talked about
the exorcist you know that was nominated
for you know best picture and stuff like
that was a horror movie but honestly
that didn't really happen again until
1991 with silence of the lambs which
some people argue isn't a horror movie
it's more like a thriller but
i don't know i'd argue it's probably a
horror movie it's pretty gory but
i don't know it's just
i kind of feel like horror
it's gotten a lot more respect over the
decades which i'm happy about because it
used to be just kind of like oh that's
some dumb slasher [ __ ]
um even though that's not
that's like a tiny subset
but even now it still seems pretty
revolutionary if a horror movie gets
nominated for anything
which is kind of sad
sci-fi and fantasy doesn't seem to have
the same
stigma but horror still kind of does
yeah tina's talking about kiss the
spider woman that was a good movie oh i
remember that one yeah that was good
that was a that was [ __ ] uh william
hurt right yeah heart was there it's
about being in a brazilian prison and a
brazilian transsexual
telling story to another guy yeah that's
right with him and it was just yeah it
was a good movie real good i haven't
seen it so long i need to see it again
i remember really i liked it i remember
really liking that i remember really
liking that
um
yeah it's just
yeah holy parachute doom says seven was
the only movie other than hereditary
where there's palpable knot of tension
throughout the audience yeah
i mean
that's
man that's the thing it's like i just
kind of wish
i don't know i don't know if i kind of
wish this or not because
being a big horror fan
i don't know if i want it to go as
mainstream i'm happy that it's more
accepted as a legitimate genre nowadays
than it used to be
because i kind of feel like
man even into the 90s
horror was still seen as some kind of
like
degenerate
or more geared toward teenagers i don't
think it was taken that seriously
it really didn't seem to be taken
seriously until maybe like the 2000s you
know
so now i mean now you actually have like
prestige horror like a24 and stuff like
that that's doing like art house horror
films and it's almost kind of like a
revamp of the 70s but
better because now at least people
respect the genre
more like to ascend with like this is
actually like a good movie it's not just
like a good horror movie
because i kind of feel like horror is
you know and maybe i'm biased because i
love horror movies and i always have
but horror is like the best genre you
can expl explore like so much
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and horror that you can't
really get away with in other genres you
know what i mean horror is just like so
diverse and it's so
you can do a lot of [ __ ] within it that
you wouldn't get away with in other
genres
um
you know you can go art house you can go
trashy you can go
uh you know you can
you can go arty and
there'll be an audience there for it
so
i mean at least in my experience i do
feel like horror audiences are a lot
more
um
a lot more varied in their interests and
a lot more
they seem a lot more like well-read a
lot more uh you know they they've seen a
lot more horror movies they seem a lot
more culturally savvy uh in the sense
that they've seen a lot more different
kinds of
uh movies and know how they relate to
the horror genre i mean just in my
experience i don't know if that's true
for everybody
khan is in the [ __ ] comment section
he's going to go eat a chicken taco he
says me
good to see you bro good to see you
um
zach said that he just got done watching
chinatown he said it's a beautiful movie
to watch i know i've never seen that one
i don't think so oh it's good jack
lemmon huh
what the heck
who's in that movie
chinatown
i was thinking of the china syndrome
that had [ __ ] but yeah that's a
totally different yeah well you know i
want to see china syndrome again okay
remember that jack lemmon well we could
do a whole so those two movies don't
have anything to do with each other but
we could do like a a china yeah whole
double feature even though those two
movies
that was another disaster flick 70s
disaster flick that was jack lemmon and
jane fonda right
i don't even remember the nuclear power
plant melting down
oh yeah yeah
yeah wait did i see that i probably did
i remember liking it as a kid i'd like
to see it again i told you i saw so many
movies
when i was growing up it's kind of like
capricorn one okay i saw so many movies
i probably saw it and forgot because i
saw so many um
yeah mango's talking about oh angel
heart flopped when it came out great
movie though yeah that's the thing i
kind of feel like
and horror is another kind of unique
genre in the sense that
sometimes a movie will come out and
honestly i just recorded a review today
it's not going up for another week or
two
or another week
of ravenous from 1999
which
was another movie that's [ __ ] awesome
and yet when it came out
nobody really got it
and so i kind of feel like it took a
really long time
but that's a nice thing about horror
it's horror fans too
um at least real horror fans not just
kind of casual horror fans they're more
kind of uh inclined to they'll watch old
[ __ ] they're not they don't have this
thing it's like oh that's old i don't
want to watch it they'll like look if
it's scary or gory or it has whatever
you want to see in it then they'll
totally watch it and they'll totally
discuss it just like it was a new movie
and i think that's like really cool uh
they seem a lot more open-minded zack
said that uh chinatown was jack
nicholson actually that's what i said
yeah it's actually sexy in it
and then i guess i mentioned something
about china syndrome and then tila jumps
in and says
it also had michael douglas in it
uh great movies oh yeah
okay
the more you the more info you're giving
me about it the more reconnect reconnect
okay
it's reconnecting
okay all right here for some reason that
you know but it's about
um jane fodder she's a
uh
investigative reporter she goes to a
nuclear power plant
and she's kind of like anti-nuclear in a
lot of ways and there's a damn
nuclear disaster from what i remember
almost happens they almost have but but
uh it is is diverted
and i think jack lemmon was in it and
who else would they say was in it uh
michael douglas yeah
yeah i remember really liking it i think
it was exciting at the day it was kind
of like
kind of like [ __ ] capricorn one
around that that
that level i want to see that one again
sorry it's going right again
don't do this to me
come on you can do it you can do it
yeah what the [ __ ] you can do it little
stream yeah
let me turn my okay victor was not
kidding i guess he doesn't like old
movies honestly i like any and this is
the same for music anything
um
i'll watch anything i don't give a [ __ ]
what year it's from
um if it's good i'll watch it
uh just like music i don't care what
music which year it's from if it's good
i'll listen to it i don't give a [ __ ] um
i kind of feel like we've come to a
point in human history nowadays
um where
we have so much access to
everything that humans have created up
to this point
and to me it just seems too
limiting to just like new [ __ ] i like
new [ __ ] i like old [ __ ] i like all the
[ __ ] yeah
honestly there's good [ __ ]
from i mean there's just so much good
[ __ ] like i said there's so much good
[ __ ] i know a lot of people like to like
focus on like you know crappy [ __ ]
there's a lot of crappy [ __ ] i'm not
saying that some of that crappy shit's
good well yeah and like i said like i
said well
and i'm kind of leaving that out because
there's some crappy [ __ ] that kind of
you know is so crappy that it becomes
good again which you know that's the
whole thing
but
i kind of feel like there's so much good
[ __ ] out there that there's really no
reason to complain and especially
nowadays we have access
to pretty much everything that's
available that has ever been created by
humankind yeah and this is a one of a
kind one of a kind in human history no
there's been nothing like this before in
the past
and don't count on this [ __ ] being
available in the future
civilizations rise and fall
we're here now we're in the here now
watch these [ __ ] movies while you can
all right understand culture understand
how good some of these movies were
most movies
suck
in any era yeah but each in every year
that movies were made
there were some good ones that [ __ ]
you got to see and there were some bad
ones that you got to see most of them
are just [ __ ] you don't have to
worry about them but there was some good
[ __ ] that he had to see and there's some
bad [ __ ] you got to see
for for different reasons
like i said i've said it before
velocipaster is not a good movie but
it's a great god damn it i love it
it's crazy [ __ ] movie it's just it
warms the cockles of my heart it's just
so
there's something that's so um
heartwarming yeah is that a weird word
to use it's so heartwarming well it knew
what it was
it was just it's just a sweet movie
i don't know it's i don't know yeah
but um
yeah the only thing that bums me out
about entertainment is that i will never
live long enough
to see all the movies i want to see and
read all the books i want to read i will
never live long enough and that like
bums me out because there's so much i
have a huge list of books and a huge
list of movies huge lists of like tv
series
all the [ __ ] i gotta see and i'm like
missing out on like so much good content
honestly like nowadays
all the [ __ ] that's coming out nowadays
it's just like i can't keep up
there's so much good [ __ ] coming out i
can't keep up for you young
whippersnappers you have to understand
something
this year there's going to be some good
movies come out
but there's a lot better there are there
are more good movies in the past
because those were already made
and there are no good movies in the
future because you haven't seen them yet
you can't see them
so you spend most of your time looking
at old movies they're trying to find
their trying to catch up to ch to catch
up trying to find the really good movies
of the past
and a lot of times these movies each one
of them kind of did different things
like
okay
three days of the condor did not do the
same thing as midnight cowboy those were
two dif those movies had two different
jobs but they were both great
and i you know it's something that they
should say you can learn from both of
them i like [ __ ] you can learn from
even if even if the learning is humorous
like i learned [ __ ] from philosopher i
learned stuff about the kung fu [ __ ]
scene
how ridiculous we were back in the 80s
when we were under the influence of kung
fu
martial arts delusions back in the 80s
when you were a kid you're like yeah
that's right we did please just do a
[ __ ]
but that's what that movie was for it
was to play it was to play with you
about what you were like when you were a
kid when you believed in ninjas
oh yeah i went back to that innocent
time yeah yeah back when you read black
belt magazine thinking that that was a
reputable magazine like that actually
touched somebody with my finger and yeah
yeah
holy parachute doom says legend of hell
house and the haunting 1963 two of my
very very favorite yeah horror movies of
all time oh my god oh and the book is
great too actually both of those books
are great
uh read the haunting of hill house by
shirley jackson 1959 and hell house
richard matheson
fantastic book both of those movie the
both of his movie adaptations were
really really good 1999 they made a
remake
of the haunting
and it blew chunks yeah holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] ever talk about missing the [ __ ]
point of the whole
point of the whole point of the story
just
there was another good
uh haunted house movie that was a low
budget california flick from the 70s
maybe early 80s called the evil
it scared the [ __ ] of me when i was a
kid and that movie has a couple of
different titles it's very underrated i
feel like that's actually a decent flick
and i liked it [ __ ] loved it uh saw
in the theater scared the [ __ ] out of me
kimmy took me to see that one
and then uh another one
was um
what was the one with the uh with the
satanist
are you gonna have to narrow it down
more one where they all meet up in the
mansion to get the gift from the [ __ ]
main sorcerer and they fed the dude to
the dogs and everything
oh uh
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that called
the
that was a good it was a british movie
real good i know what you're talking
about um
the legacy the legacy
i was like it was a word it was a word
it started with an l
yeah
that's another one it's kind of it's
kind of like uh it's kind of like
haunting a hell house in a way a bunch
of witches go back to this mansion in
england
for this big meeting
and you got some people that are there
that are just they're just americans
they're just american as [ __ ] they don't
know anything about what the hell's
going on there's any kind of a on it's
just
americans they're
what the [ __ ] are these british people
doing and they turned out that this is a
damn witch's coven
and they're all kind of
vying to [ __ ] inherit the power of
the [ __ ]
satanic [ __ ]
warlock master and he wipes them out
it's a good movie i mean you're going to
give me this mansion and all the money
and also magical powers all right right
yeah it's called the legacy i'm first in
line for that [ __ ] real good it's like
just right here if anybody wants to give
me that i'm just got it i got it on
blu-ray i [ __ ] loved it and jenny
never seen it i showed it to her she
liked it i had yeah i'd seen it you
hadn't seen it before yeah i thought you
didn't see that one okay
i told you i've seen everything yeah you
didn't see the [ __ ] loved one though
no i hadn't showed her the loved one and
she was like man this is a how did i not
know about this movie i've seen most
things okay i've seen 95 of things yeah
um i don't remember sometimes sometimes
i don't remember like and then i'll see
it and then be like oh wait [ __ ] i've
seen this you know what i mean uh
because i saw so many movies tila have
you seen the loved one it's a black and
white movie from the 16th we did a
matinee on it like not too long ago
and it's uh
it's like a black comedy yeah it's kind
of like
the um
kind of like uh
dr strangelove of the funeral industry
see and that's like exactly
my sense of humor yeah i was talking
earlier about how i'm really like
reluctant to watch comedies because a
lot of them are not funny to me
that was funny to me it was weird yeah
that was funny to me
yeah and it was
kind of humor in the 60s it would
probably have been more outrageous
but today it's just kind of like
yeah that's the way it really is yeah
but to be honest with you i can kind of
extrapolate back to the time period when
this came out and i'm like wow this was
like really subversive
for the time that it came out
yeah i mean she'd never seen it no see
the loved one it's black and white uh
jonathan winters is in it uh who's
[ __ ] great he plays like four or five
roles in it
um i thought it was like i thought it
was really funny yeah like i said that's
like my sense of humor though it's about
this british dude who moves to [ __ ]
hollywood
to hang out with his gay uncle and he
kills himself
and then i mean the gay uncle killed the
gay uncle kills himself and the body's
taken to a place to have it buried
and he gets involved with this damn
funeral business it's a cemetery that
has a whole [ __ ] funeral business
behind it's kind of like a cult okay
and he falls into it because there's a
real cute
girl working there it's all these cute
proto goth 1960s girls
working in there as morticians and
[ __ ] all kinds of and and and her
name is miss thanatogenous and [ __ ]
he's all in this myth
miss thanatogenous chick and the more he
falls into this basically it's a
corporate
funeral parlor
and the weirder it gets you know what i
mean
i love it yeah it's good it's a good
movie and it's weird i love it he's
trying to chase this proto-gothic chick
down this rabbit hole and it just gets
weirder and weirder and then the space
industry gets involved in it and
everything
it's a good movie shooting some remains
into space yeah yeah it's the whole
thing yeah
winners plays like the [ __ ] funeral
home owner who's
well actually he plays the director and
the owner yeah he plays like four or
five different roles and he plays the
dude who owns the [ __ ] space industry
the private space industry he's got to
see it
the loved one it's good
it's classic i honestly i can't believe
that a movie like that got made
the year that it got made yeah and she
had never seen it i saw it on tv as a
kid and it blew well you showed it to me
and i was just kind of like how did i
not see this
this is exactly yeah i was like this is
all the [ __ ] i like in one movie yeah
in one movie yeah and it's just weird
it's really weird and it is hilarious
like i said that's exactly my sense of
humor yeah that's exactly my sense of
humor i was like i was down
um
holy parish of doom says check out the
found footage flick the conspiracy i've
actually seen it uh i actually did a
review of it
a couple months ago
yeah that's like a found footage
mockumentary type thing and actually was
really really good uh so if you haven't
seen it like go check it out it might be
on shutter
or to be i can't remember um i think i
watched it on shutter but i don't know
if it's on there anymore at this point
because that was like a few
uh months back that i watched it
granthar's hammer says
where oh i lost it tila said that the
[ __ ] lover was only already on her
watch list we must have talked about
yeah we talked about it we did yeah we
did a review of it yeah um grand theft
auto says other topics do young goths of
today understand the struggle of gods
yesterday no no well they don't care
either
well they didn't have to do it so and
and i'm not gonna be one of those i
never ever even when i was
a teenager
i told myself when i get old i'm never
gonna be one of those people that is
gonna be like in my day
you know what i mean i still i do it
sometimes i get it but
i'm trying not to do that i don't want
to be that person
but
you know the cultural context is much
much different so they don't have to put
up with a lot of the [ __ ] that we
had to put up with yeah because
like i said growing up in the 80s no one
really had a
they didn't have a net they didn't have
a framework to understand what it was no
one no one knew who tim burton was
nobody knew who marilyn manson was
nobody like so nobody knew what that was
about like so you dressed like that
everybody just thought are you a
satanist or are you doing witchcraft on
me or [ __ ] like that and then marilyn
manson came out they says oh you're some
kind of weird sexual pervert thing like
and then i'm not sure that made it
better no made it worse it didn't really
make it better it took a while for it it
took a while for
the old people to [ __ ] i think i kind
of preferred it when nobody knew what
what the deal was and they just didn't
know what your deal was yeah i think
that was kind of better once people
started associating because once
once um i was walking through the mall
or something in daytona beach and
somebody said beetlejuice at me yeah uh
in the late 80s i was just kind of like
oh dear this is going to be like this
from now on right yeah tina said the
phantasm is terribly underrated
well not only phantasm but all five of
those movies are terribly underrated i
loved that's the best all of the fantasy
movies the phantasm
series
is the most solid horror series out of
all of them
good because friday the 13th can't claim
that friday the 13th some of those
movies were very weak
but every [ __ ] movie out of all five
phantasm movies were um
made with love
they were the
pretty much the i think except except
three
three i think a studio did that right
one no two so is it two or three okay
but i would argue that even though a
studio did the second one the second one
is actually quite often still good yeah
it's quite awesome but they were all
labors of love by a the singular vision
of one man and he also stars in those
damn movies
well it's nice well it's don coskarelli
that made them uh reg reg is the dude
that's in it but they were friends
though yeah and that says two guys i
guess yeah there's two guys here yeah
but there's no great movies great the
thing about phantasm is that it's just
such a weird
concept and you can go in so many
different directions
we need to watch that one again we need
to refresh on that honestly yeah of all
the movie franchises
i think
phantasm is
the most consistently good i enjoyed
every single phantasm movie i think part
of it was because it was horror fantasy
yeah this is involving other dimensions
and weird [ __ ] and different that's what
i mean you could kind of like you could
so there was a lot of ways you could go
with it yeah you weren't like limited to
because friday the 13th you're kind of
limited to you could have jason he's
gotta have the machete he's gotta like
slash up teenagers blah blah so there's
only so much you can do with that uh
which is fine but phantasm you introduce
that supernatural element which
didn't work as well for nightmare on elm
street because nightmare and elm street
also kind of has a supernatural or at
least a dream like element um which
sometimes works really well and
sometimes not but i kind of feel like
phantasm is kind of its own thing
phantasm
all of there are five movies yeah i
think there's five movies yeah
every single one of them really end
honestly every single one of them is
worth watching yeah the only thing that
ever comes would ever come close in the
in that genre would be evil dead and all
the the offshoots from the evil dead
like the tv series and everything close
i think that's about on par
but there's something about phantasm it
had its own
special mix of [ __ ] crazy
you know see i love it was his own thing
weird [ __ ] like that yeah
and i love
i think the reason i love phantasm is
because it's just unapologetically
weird yeah
the little midgets from another
dimension doing weird things with bodies
weird possessions women not being what
they appear to be
reggie being a sex symbol that was a
[ __ ] that was a what reggie's the sex
symbol yeah
the badass car oh my god reggie i love
your head yeah and then and then it
ended basically with an apocalyptic
with an apocalyptic motif that the world
is now over and and the other dimension
has now encroached onto this dimension
and we now have to survive they're out
here and if there's ever a six
there they've they've left it to where
six would be badass
well see like i said i think that's the
best thing about phantasm is that
they
it's unapologetically weird they don't
over explain anything
they're just kind of like yeah there's
midgets yeah there's other dimensions
we're just like not gonna
we're not gonna like discuss it at
length
we're just gonna like let it
lay there and i think that's better yeah
it has this whole weird tone about it
that i feel like has not been matched in
another
uh horror franchise in the same way um
and you know like i said i'm not averse
to horror franchise i'm not a big fan of
like sequels and [ __ ] i will watch them
but
i can't think of another
horror franchise
that i've enjoyed every single movie in
the franchise except for phantasm yeah
every single
one of the five movies and the phantasm
uh franchise i have actually really
really liked yeah most of them are on
shutter or they were because we watched
all of them like in one night i think we
have some
yeah but uh some of you were saying that
rav
number five which is ravager was like
[ __ ] reviled i don't understand why i
like five i liked all of them it just it
just got crazier and crazier as they
went i mean what happens sometimes in
fandoms is that fans get [ __ ] wired
into one thing they want the same thing
over and over again
the five had the same cast a lot of the
same you know the and it was it was just
it was just becoming a little more
modernized you know in certain ways they
were trying to expand the story out
and it was probably going to be the last
one but i liked five i liked them all i
liked them all
i did it as well yeah
and i don't think i can say that for
can i think of any other horror
franchise where i can say that
no the evil deaths are okay yeah all the
evil deads are good and all the
spin-offs of that i think that's the
only thing close to it would be the evil
dead yeah that would be my second pick
right um
everything else there's at least a
flawed movie in there somewhere yeah and
um you know honestly as much as i like
nightmare and elm street
uh i love the first movie i love the
third movie i like some of the other
ones i like new nightmare uh the wes
craven wes grovin's new nightmare uh but
some of those were kind of
yeah
i only liked the first one and the
second one didn't the second one have
little blonde what's her name the little
cutie pie
one that's from true romance
no that was the third one there was the
third one what was her name um
the arquette arquette yeah patricia she
was god she was so cute that was the
third one yeah third one the second one
was the one with all the homoerotic
subtext yeah
which i didn't like at the time but
actually re-watching it recently
i have a new appreciation for it um
although i will say that i didn't really
like like the first nightmare on elm
street
was actually like pretty legit scary
like it had like some really creepy
scenes in it
i didn't really like the more comedic
route that it went
i'm not [ __ ] on horror comedies i do
like horror comedies
but
you have to really have a deft hand
to pull that off
um i feel like most horror comedies fall
more on the comedy side
it's a comedy but it has horror elements
in it
rather than a horror movie that's
actually scary but is also funny
um that doesn't happen all that often
yeah business just jumped in and goes
did they show the shot glass yeah we
showed the shot glass do you want us to
show it again show the shot glasses
maybe people didn't show it again yeah
yeah we showed it like near the
beginning right right
so uh tom's gonna talk about this i'm
not sure like i don't want to get it too
close to the camera because i don't know
if they're going to like flag it
yeah because it's it's a shot glass from
tijuana
it's got
agave on the front it's either agave or
weed i think it's a gobbler i think it's
a guy it's agave and then
you've got a mexican dude falling down
into the damn
shot glass his pants are down around his
knees nothing but just [ __ ]
balls and [ __ ] [ __ ] coming at you so
if you ever take a damn drink out of
this [ __ ] your [ __ ] nose goes into
his ass that's like that's the joke
that's a joke yeah that's very cool yeah
yeah you got your um
uh as
as they would say in the uk wedding
tackle yeah they call it the wedding
tackle
um
and i was i was telling tom earlier i
was like i was trying to imagine a
scenario of how that happened in which
this dude would end up like this in real
life i can't really think of one and
look the it's a it's corona
right there and it's kind of like stuck
to it like no one's hanging on to it
it's just kind of like stuck to his
thigh i love it
but i think the reason they did that was
just that so you could drink
your tequila shot or whatever like out
of this and your nose would go right
into his teeth yeah zachary says he
wants one of those
yeah
yeah and then now let's talk about
true romance look at this
little look at his little ball sack yeah
true romance was a [ __ ] classic man i
love that i love trumburger yeah yeah i
love charlie
christian slater
gary oldman patricia arquette there's a
good flick and uh it was a quentin
tarantino wrote it he didn't direct it
though yeah which might have been a good
thing because tarantino probably would
have [ __ ] that one up i think a little
bit in some ways because
uh the director who did this when connor
did tarantino's material he did it kind
of straight
um if if he'd put tarantino in charge of
that [ __ ] he would have [ __ ]
probably would have
them
gone crazy with it like he does with
some of his i'm gonna cast myself in
this just so i can say the n word over
and over right super shocking it makes
me cool that i could say that
jackson [ __ ] using that damn look i'm
saying the edward and samuel l jackson
is not punching his face
that means i'm
cool not no you're not okay
anyway uh but not i like quentin terry
yeah i'm not i'm not hating on quentin
he's his best but i love him we went to
the same middle school together
he was a couple years older than me and
[ __ ] he grew up working this and this
is in [ __ ] carson california all
right he went he went to
um
uh
[ __ ]
right down to the end of jackson street
dominguez elementary school that's where
he went
he was a little bit older than me i
thought he might have been the same age
as me but i worked it out the dates
he was older than me
i thought he was in my class but he
wasn't
but uh he
[ __ ] if you're listening to me we went
to school together i remember you i
remember you but uh anyway
he worked in the department i liked all
of his he worked at the video store at
the corner there right there near the
mexican restaurant where my dad used to
eat all the time he used to take me down
there man this is good it's called a wet
burrito
yeah
never heard of him
your dad was so cultured yeah
well looking back on it though he was
flirting with that mexican waitress that
was in there oh okay well then yeah she
was cute
and uh they had their wet breeder with
the green salsa on there it was good
it's called el ranchita el ranchitos i
think it's called el ranchitos what's
the name of the place i think it was el
ranchitos or i think i think so
it was um
yeah wrap the street from dominguez
elementary i could find that [ __ ] on i
could find it on on google earth
if i would google maps i could go back
there should i enter up you for a second
because somebody said maddie p 3400 says
saw a field in england last night you
were talking about kill list and ben
wheaton the other day um i'm gonna get
to a field in england because i love
that movie um so yeah so i did kill this
first but i will do a field in england i
have seen it and that's a really good
movie so i just wanted to like say that
but he he worked at the damn video store
up the street
and that was over there near back we
used to play on the other side of the
damn railroad tracks looking for them
dead dogs behind [ __ ] dominguez
elementary that's where they built that
[ __ ] oh my god you're just like
standing by me yeah it was like that
look i found a dead body in the railroad
track no i didn't look for that [ __ ]
they had the [ __ ] water pollution
control factory and [ __ ] they had the
[ __ ] where the giant ants from them yeah
they had all that terminator jumping
down in the damn motorcycle that's
that's where i grew up with [ __ ] from
that phase
and uh
but behind dominguez elementary they
built all those [ __ ]
things and that's where jesse james
[ __ ] motorcycle shop was was back
there
and i think he was from that area for
all i know i went to high school for all
i know i went to middle school with him
i bet you because i think he was from
there
i had to go back there and look i don't
know what his real name is zach says tom
you still have to get your dad on the
phone
and put it on the show
to make him tell stories i want to hear
his real voice it sounds just like i
told you it sounds doesn't it uh yeah it
just sounds just like that
[Laughter]
when he does the boy that's that's
that's exactly what his death sounds
like what is streaming streaming what
no we're live dad we're doing live
we live right now how many people listen
to god damn
god damn
you tell him about a chicken necks and
said yeah all about turkey decks yeah
yeah
i thought i had turkey
i need to call him one time did you tell
him that we like talked about his name
on your turkey in it no no oh you didn't
tell him that call him and and say
we're safe i don't think he knows how to
like listen to a live stream on youtube
no he doesn't have internet oh it's not
gonna be like
he's not really sure what it is okay
we're talking about you and the turkey
next tell them about the turkey next huh
some who's listening who's there he
thinks they're in the room
i don't know
you don't know
all right i'll tell it i'll tell it you
know
he'd be like that i know exactly how
he's on he's on a system he's
there there there's there's the app
that there's a tom
you can kind of predict what he'll do
yeah
get him to talk about the bible they'll
tell you how it's all true that's
another thing
everyone
i said that's not dead
he thinks it's all true
but he doesn't know much about it
it's just he's just a man of his times
and he's frozen in the 80s really frozen
in the 80s that
if you go back to where he lives it's
still the 80s kind of
that's so weird yeah i don't even
remember like i kind of remember the 80s
but not really
and i lived through this [ __ ] yeah
it happens
that's that's why it's like a i remember
the music the music was good but other
than that i'm just kind of like what was
it even like back then i don't i don't
remember real comfortable with his
friends in that house over there in
[ __ ] heidelberg mississippi that's
cool and nothing's changing i mean just
you live the way you want to live i'm
not [ __ ] on it like
[Laughter]
he thinks the internet is all about
[ __ ] it's all [ __ ] oh
yeah
that's funny
you can't change them
it's just the way certain people are
although that's bad though because
you're missing out on a lot of stuff
when he came out i showed him [ __ ]
youtube and i said what is it you want
to know what
he likes guns is what kind of gun you're
looking for and he he came with some
like of some obscure early 1900s stuff
and i [ __ ] pulled it up there's a
whole video on youtube about it his mind
was blown he's like there it is that's
it
that's it damn that was on there
damn
how much is on there you know who put
that on there
like that you know damn so it's like
he's moving forward into the future
you met him he's he's like at that time
he's like another time
that's like that blows my mind though
that there are still people like i know
because my grandma was like that too
yeah yeah um she didn't even want to
touch the computer she's like i'll break
it yeah right yeah she won't touch it
yeah
my dad was just amazing
about that okay
he said yeah i'm checking out he can
barely use a phone i'm checking out so
you can barely use a phone but that's
not like that's not everybody though
because i see old people all the time
like using [ __ ] smartphones it's his
priorities yeah you know well he's not
in a in a you know cultural context
where he has to no he doesn't need any
of that
i mean from our point of view even
though we're old too yeah um you know
i'm almost 50.
but
we grew up with computers i mean i grew
up with computers yeah
even though they were like apple two e's
and you had to like program yourself
there was no windows it's just the way
guys like that are that's how they go
you and
yeah he lived he had his time and you
know he's towards the end of his time
but he had his time and he did his thing
and he's happy
so
just let it be
i mean i get that i do get to a point
where and especially nowadays because
so much stuff like shit's happening like
so fast that everybody's just like all
right i'm saying i'm checking out right
now right yeah but information overload
right it is yeah but
i mean
you ha you also have to kind of like
like laser focus your [ __ ] it's like
what do you
want to achieve what are you interested
in
and just kind of like concentrate on
that right don't worry about like
learning everything right well that's
the way he's doing because at his age
there's nothing he can do about anything
that's going on he's he's just pissed
that he can't fish
yeah yeah tommy need to come down here
tight because his friend tommy key tommy
need to come down here and take me
fishing you know i got this thing on he
don't want to tell he's afraid i'm gonna
get a heart attack and then i'll be out
there at the water and i said if i die
out there on the water what difference
does it make i'm going to die anyway i
better not die on the water out there if
i could fish it
he don't want to be responsible
which that's understandable yeah yeah
you don't want to watch it you don't
want to be out down the boat when like
your friend dies yeah well his friends
won't take him fishing because there's a
dive while he's fishing and they can't
get into the bank fast enough and that's
[ __ ] pissed my dad off he's like [ __ ]
it if i die on the water then let me die
in the water i'm gonna die anyway i
totally understand what he's talking
about i can't understand it doesn't it
but i understand his friend's point of
view yeah he's friends nobody wants to
be like responsible possible
for a dude that like dies in the boat
you're right yeah when you're on the
boat it's like
this is the thing that we have to deal
with right because he i know exactly
what would happen because keys [ __ ]
wife would be like you shouldn't have
taken him out there that's what it
happened because they all got wise he
knows
he's on his dead bed anyway you
shouldn't take his ass down there that's
how they are
and then they're never living down
well you know
tommy wanted to go out that way
these are [ __ ] mississippi country
[ __ ] but they're not dumb
they're not not dumb at all it's just
that they they're like the ewoks from
star
way of doing wars
and like i said that's totally fine and
honestly i'm not going to [ __ ] on
anybody for
look if you want to check out a [ __ ] and
you just want to like look i'm just
going to do this one [ __ ] narrow
thing it's like you know i'm old i'm
going to die soon it's like i'm just
going to do this and everything this
makes me happy
then just do that
no like don't feel like you have to
do some other [ __ ] like don't make other
people happy just make yourself i take
him out there fishing
maybe you should
yeah maybe i should just go ahead and go
fishing maybe you should maybe you
should go out and see your dad yeah well
yeah i eventually have to i mean you're
gonna have to yeah that probably is
taking fishing
yeah i was thinking about that uh the
other day because you got all the stuff
well i think i was thinking about it
i think i was thinking about it because
uh as we talked about on our
pre-halloween show
um
you know our friend kaylee yeah
uh passed away yeah recently uh